Just just like silence.
We just wait for the Magic to happen.
Ari,
sometimes I don't want to prepare your ego's magic trust.
Trust in the muse.
[inaudible] [inaudible] straight as they come.
You go about Shawntay they all had from this
[inaudible] [inaudible] we would
ask for,
uh,
you could die.
[inaudible]
but the baby
[inaudible] [inaudible] this
song makes me feel like I walked down a,
a gay couple arguing.
It actually sounds like the credits of Jennifer Aniston movie.
Yeah,
right at the end.
Like she's jumping up and down in the fall leaves,
they're frozen in the air and her dog is barking and then it freezes and then a
song comes on and you go,
okay,
now I can take her home and fucker.
Cause I took her to a Jennifer Aniston movie.
Say Jennifer Anderson got a good job.
She did.
No,
whatever that movie was.
Ladies and gentlemen joining us today on the podcast,
we have the one and only Mr. Are you sure?
Hey Aria,
a,
r I s.
H.
A.
F.
I r on Twitter bitches followed that home boy home,
home,
home boy.
Also joining us is the one and only mad flavor.
Aka Joe Diaz,
Aka Planet Rock.
You would plant it Ron for like a month.
Remember the like let it rot.
I like it too.
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for you to bring it to pass that out soon.
You know what I'm saying?
What Berkeley's doing well out there in podcast land pop,
planet rock will come out on new years.
Fuck yeah.
Well we don't,
we're not doing a new year's show folks.
The Mandalay Bay and the,
uh,
the ticket people that put up the link,
you,
it got complicated and it didn't look like there's going to be enough time to
sell tickets.
So we bailed and then we're coming back February on
the Superbowl weekend.
So cancel your tickets.
All you people get your fucking miles back.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened.
If you bang them,
you could see anybody bought any tickets.
I don't think the linkedin go up yet,
so I'm pretty sure it wasn't available.
It just was too close.
It was too close where it was too annoying.
So we got it back.
Uh,
four February 4th.
It looks like have all weekend for a weekend.
Wow.
It should be fun.
We don't allow full,
and this is Silva Rich Franklin.
Who else?
And we'll have a link up for that in a couple of days on Superbowl weekend cause
rich frankly,
I don't know.
Beta and Jon Jones.
Really?
Yes.
That's the three of the car.
Check it out.
I don't know that because this is what I do.
I call you on the ground.
You know what I'm saying?
I hear you're a soldier soldier.
It's Franklin against the other guy.
I think this show is sponsored by one of my favorites.
Drop it.
The fleshlight lationships.
No recipes.
This,
we'll talk some real company that pays money to get to keep the show rolling and
we appreciate them and it's an excellent product.
Okay.
It's an embarrassing situation.
A lot of people don't want to admit the masturbate,
but if you're,
if you're a fan of aliens and that one definitely you like this one,
that's a good one.
That's my favorite one.
For your penis or your tractor from urban assembly.
Tell me more.
It just as a little bit better texture than the other ones I have inside cars.
Inside there's actually like three different alien texture.
Makes sense because you're,
you know,
you're really into technology.
It would make sense.
You'd really be in a fucking line alien.
Yeah.
If you go to Joe rogan.net there's a link for the fleshlight.
You get 15% off.
Like I said,
I endorse it is a good product.
It's an embarrassing product.
You know,
let's say a coffee mug.
It's probably kept me from getting an audition or two,
but that's okay.
It's fun.
It's good.
When you're by yourself,
you stone,
you don't want to call nobody.
And when I talk to nobody there,
you want a hotel room,
you take it to the hallway,
we your role bothering you slip as you fill it up with ice,
you come back,
you put the fucking little artificial monkey back in there and you're bang one
out with some ice cubes and he gets a Mescalin well pussy and you go to bed and
you come in the cup and then you fucking wait till the melts and whatever you
do.
You know he come to the cup.
What?
I'm gonna fuck it.
You have a good time.
Everybody wants to have a good time.
I have this big problem with my animals right now.
After I masturbate,
not using the flashlight,
I out like come in like a Napkin and put it on my nightstand.
And that means,
oh my cat loves napkin balls and paper balls.
So the cat throws on the ground where the dog likes to eat toilet paper.
So then the dog eats it.
So it's like this whole teen tag of eating my com and it ends up in my dog's
mouth.
Goes pregnant,
comes out with a fucking iPhone cop stuff.
Dirty bastard.
You got the call fucking America's most wanted you to fill be fucked.
I don't do it on purpose.
Come on it already.
Fuck.
Well,
all right,
so you're so you just shoot loads and just immediately blackout.
Yes.
3:00 AM I'm saying,
you know this is only when I don't use the flashlight,
like 3:00 AM come home drunk,
put it in a Napkin,
put it on my nightstand next day I hear cat shuffling like that and then next
thing I know dog grabs ball off the ground or we're letting me there.
Not Bad.
Why don't you come and
your fucking hands,
they wipe it on the sheet.
I'm on your pillow case like guys,
I'm that's gross or come in a sock or something.
But you can't come on that.
Do you want us off?
They're going to recycle that shit.
Somebody going to wipe their fucking at you know what I'm saying?
I'm if,
well,
if the,
if it's the cat's fault though,
the cat one cat things.
It's hilarious to,
if the dog eats my comments,
your resistance to sleep after you shoot your loads,
that's the issue.
You just,
that's what I pictured you shooting along.
Why Lingo and the last thing I want dog cleanup crouching for food dogs got
nine.
No,
you don't do much.
All right.
When you walk off,
that's what that mother stays in.
You lay on it and you wake up and put a shirt over it.
Like fucking nothing happened.
Like,
Hey,
wake up.
You don't give a fuck.
I don't blame you.
The inside out sock and I throw it next to the bed and it just,
it just,
you have like 20 socks would fucking [inaudible] and trees and mushrooms that,
you know,
there was a line in my act,
but it's so true that I can't remember how many times did I shot a load on my
stomach.
I just put my shirt on and just left,
took off,
pull my shirt down and you know,
never bothered wipe myself off the fucking food in your belly button.
You know what I'm saying?
Bats are flying out of there at the store with the fucking calm.
Kicked all of your stomach and how many times have you done that?
All Day.
If I'm lazy,
if I've worked too hard,
I got too much shit I got to do.
I'll just wipe it up,
shoot loads of my chest hairs and leave them there.
Don't give up.
Like I said,
that's what's good about being uncircumcised.
Sometimes I whack off and I just hold it at the tip and it swells up like a Boa
constrictor and I just sit there for like a minute.
I can go on and unloaded in the fucking toilet [inaudible] meeting and it comes
right out.
One fucking shot you file.
So if you uncircumcised do that,
just whack often common and just hold the tip.
You can watch TV till the next bucket commercial.
You know what I'm saying?
It swells up like a Boa constrictor.
He got ahold of tight.
Everybody's looking at me like it looks like a balloon.
Like hello.
You know what I'm saying?
I got the Cuban egg one I just looked at.
It comes all out.
I pulled the skin back.
I dry off the helmet and somebody that lay his drinking my fucking so I get a
full picture.
What color is your sperm?
Like yours,
I guess.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
Your loads would be like normal Cuban.
I like 10 like if you got that mic again.
Yes.
All right.
Don't worry.
I won't touch it.
Maybe it's not connected,
right Brian?
Well hold on.
We're all right.
I won't touch that.
I'm good right here.
Right off.
Joey Diaz is Mike Right now.
Grab it and try to push it up.
Yeah,
son of a bitch.
What is happening
every time someone touches that last week may him was,
oh,
it was killing my ears because every time he just accidentally bump into it,
it makes this really loud pop.
That's amazing.
You're actually doing this with studio style microphones in your home and we
don't fuck around dog.
Okay.
I like zone.
Well,
we started out with this bald that was this like stupid thing that you buy USP
check.
Is that good?
Yeah.
Nah Man,
I ain't got to touch it.
I ain't got to talk.
Are It going?
It's not going to touch on it now we're good right there.
Put the things like Jesus Christ.
That's good right there.
I won't touch it.
All right now I got help me fucking helmet juice healthy.
How much is no blood?
No,
no.
One time.
I had a couple of years ago.
What does that four what does that,
I went right to Bob hope.
Dope the next day.
Cause don't doctor the is the best doctor at Blah Blah dope.
And I told them right off the bat,
I said Doctor [inaudible] and I looked at him straight in the face and I came
last night and it was a little blood and he looked at him.
He goes,
so what?
that happened Jay once in a while in the party so you can come.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Everything was good.
It happened sometime you cut a lot of fucking blood.
That's when it's bad.
It's bad if you come,
how much is a lot?
Well,
I came one time,
the amount of blood tack,
you know,
maybe you get kicked in the nut and concluded were telling him about the time I
came home and my Dick was broken us.
Oh,
you went
did Jujitsu.
Right.
And I'm rolling.
My friend Einstein and he,
uh,
Scott Epstein and he goes to pass my guard and slams his knee right into my
dick.
I didn't have a cup back then.
I didn't wear a cup.
This is the incident that made me wear a cup,
not my balls button.
My Dick like Bam,
sorry.
Right on my deck.
Very,
very painful.
Right.
So I deal with it,
you know,
and then I go right back to Roland.
You know,
I,
I take a couple of minutes off and then once I'm okay,
I get back in there and it really rocked me though.
So then I get off,
I get out of Jujitsu class and I go to take my,
a jock strap off and there's blood in it.
It's like all blood and I'm like,
oh,
fuck soaked.
Yeah.
Was soaked.
The whole thing's red.
And then I'm looking down,
I'm like,
oh fuck.
And then I look at my Dick and my dick is bleeding out a tip.
So I piss okay.
And when I pissed,
I see all kinds of blood and shit in my pants and I'm like,
God,
fuck.
So now I'm thinking,
what do I do now?
Do I go to the doctor?
Because if it was you know,
my nose,
what would I do?
I would just go home.
I just,
what am I going?
What are they going to do?
They're not going to do anything.
So I said,
well am I being over sensitive cause this is my deck.
Yeah,
I am so just go home.
So I got home and then it was freaking me out.
Like what if my Dick is broken?
What if something,
some serious damage.
So I forced myself to jerk off the dessert.
No,
it didn't hurt that bad.
What were you thinking?
I just want her to see if I could still get a hard on,
if I could still get a hard on.
I was sure that there was nothing wrong with my deck and yeah,
it was fine.
I shot a load and my load was like,
it was like pinkish red streaks in it and shit.
I did beautiful.
I did a bottom zipper thing where you does it the bottom of your Dick one that
I've done that and it was so fucking bad that it just was like this big scar for
awhile and know chick,
but the river wants to believe that either.
By the way,
I had the old,
no chick wants to just hear.
Oh yes,
it's a zipper.
My zipper guy.
How
about circumcised?
You don't know what it is to catch your fucking Dick in music.
My Dick looks like limitation of my little's for skin.
Looks like Frankenstein's forehead dog.
Got Stitches in that mother fucker.
Everything I show you right now,
I got a fucking scar on my helmet from like when I was about eight.
I caught that turtleneck.
I left it there for two days I think one time.
Oh God.
I was pissing sideways.
I'll leave my pants on.
Took like two days.
I taught them.
I was a soldier.
Even Ben on his show bombed.
He got with crawling up,
losing your mom,
put peroxide.
I lived those shorts.
My mom could say,
well,
how come no shortcuts though?
I leave it there and he's like a little buckle like this.
Put your keys in it so I can totally,
if I don't have this,
I'll lose my fucking keys a little.
Did she know I had the Zipper?
That's when they put a big flap over your zipper.
I had the zip across the fucking flap.
So you left [inaudible] I couldn't,
I couldn't pull it out of pain was fucking awful.
So you just left it.
I love when I watch some about Mary,
that guys one fucking day called the ambulance.
I walked around for two fucking days.
I still got a scar.
That dog,
she's crushed it on zip it.
I didn't want to show nobody.
That's embarrassing.
When you're writing,
you've got to go to your mom and say,
you know,
have you ever jumped off so much or obsessively to the point where you got a
blister on your deck?
No.
No,
no,
I haven't.
I haven't had a lot of still a blister.
I'm a chronic masturbator.
Yes.
Fleshlight company understands me more.
Wait time.
How many times?
I want to know how many times you've had blisters.
I've done it and then a couple minutes later go go.
I can remember going to mass weight.
I just masturbate.
Like what's like,
what's in a normal week for you though?
Like three a day.
Three every day.
Sure.
What are your loads look like?
Mornings,
mid afternoon.
Nightmare today for everyone.
So what do your loads look like?
Please describe your loads.
Uh,
pretty watery.
It's mostly just power aid orange.
After a while
it looks like power eliminated probably.
Oh No,
patty.
Yeah.
I want to know how long it takes to refuel your helmet after you shoot a logo.
It's like 10 minutes.
Soldiers.
All right,
let's look that up.
Joe Rogan and your first,
your first load.
Most
the,
the the most loads are to kill other sperm.
That's what most of your sperms for most of your sperm is to go and seek out
other people sperm inside the girl's vagina and kill it.
Wow.
That's pretty crazy.
They say that the PR,
the rate of promiscuous women is directly proportional to the men with big balls
and the men with big balls.
The reason why they're growing big balls around all these women is because these
women are promiscuous and so they have to develop more killer sperm that go in
and assault all the other sperm.
I've always had a giant balls you fear from a family of whores,
whores and sluts and you just constantly run chicks and one extra dick.
And when you're around that,
that's a different level of competition.
I don't have big balls.
Nice.
I read science journals,
brother read.
Uh,
it's all fascinating stuff,
man.
Well they don't say big balls.
I say Tufts.
That's a,
that's the case with animals as well.
The case of the animals in the kingdom,
the animals that have
the biggest balls are the ones that are in fierce competition with other males
to get laid.
Yeah.
The you,
your,
your loads will actually kill other loads.
Is refugees trying to get them pregnant?
There's yeah.
Soldiers in your loads are soldiers and they're not even there to make babies.
There's a bunch of them that are specifically there to find other sperm and put
the beaten on them.
It's a war.
It's a war inside her pussy.
That's what it is,
man.
The reason why manners so fucking competitive with each other constantly.
It's because we have where we have a factory of sperm killers that were grown
inside of our body to combat other dudes.
So I don't want the other loads are already there.
What if your loads and their loads got together and became friends who shot like
peaceful loads?
What if they came out?
We don't have any load.
He tastes.
Yeah,
and they're just constantly dripping loads out.
The fuck is wrong with them.
Grew in this huge bubble of loads.
It's out of her ovaries.
She's developed a whole colony of loads.
Yeah.
Just living together.
They've figured out how to survive off moisture.
Have you heard that thing about life?
That they found a new form of life?
NASA found a form of life that's arsenic based,
so it evolved in a completely different environment than human beings and it
just changed their whole picture of what life can be like.
They never thought that that would be possible.
So explain more,
well,
I'd have to go and read it.
It's a whole new form of life.
Did send in La,
they live with arsenic.
Arsenic is a part of their being.
I think it replay,
I forget what it replaces.
I think phosphorus,
I'm not sure,
but it replaces something that our life is based on.
But basically what the idea is,
it's not a parallel growth.
It's like these things evolve on their own.
It's a different form of life that evolved on its own and it's only like a
bacteria,
but it's still,
it's a different form of life.
It means that if life got more complicated with,
you know,
the,
the carbon based life that we have could get more complicated with their life as
well.
There could be some sort of super intelligent life that's totally outside of our
realm of imagination.
We can never guess it.
So they have to relook at all of these other planets that they thought wasn't
suitable for life.
Now they have to kind of re look at it and go,
well maybe it is.
It's a different kind of life.
We're assuming that the only kind of life that gets to be super intelligent and
can control the world,
his life like us,
but so it says who says fucking who we,
there could be some crazy shit on Venus.
There can be not probably not Venus,
but you know,
and some other planets that we,
you know,
that has a totally different alien atmosphere and it's totally,
totally different.
You know,
a food supply and totally different temperatures and the media kids,
that could be some nutty shit out there,
man.
They found a new fucking planet.
How about this?
They're not,
they don't know what it is,
but they believe there's a Jupiter size object just outside of our solar system.
It's a long way away,
but it's fucking huge.
And I tried to wrap their head around it.
Right now,
they don't know exactly what it is or how big it is or how far out it is,
but there's a very good chance that there's a Jupiter size fucking planet.
Jupiter is the biggest planet in our solar system.
One outside of Pluto outside that Kuyper belt,
they've been,
I've heard scientists talk about this in the past.
Apparently there's something goes on at the end of space.
That's something about the galactic shelf and the ideas that they can gauge like
how many objects are in the Kuyper belt.
There's like a drop off at a certain point and they think that the only way that
that drop off would be there is if there's a large body that has a lot of
gravity.
And so they were thinking that at one point in time maybe there was a planet,
but now they're really sure.
Now it's getting much,
much more likely.
That's pretty crazy shit man.
If there's something out there and it's apparently whey the fuck out there,
like further from Pluto than we are from Pluto,
you know,
it's fucking out there.
But it's big.
That's close.
That's scary.
Close.
You know,
are people in there?
Tude that's,
that's,
that's an appear man.
When he comes into focus,
when we learn about it,
that's when we learned about the Annunaki.
Did you guys see that plan at the other day when you guys had a little bit of
fun Dunoon do the asset?
No,
I did not see that.
This is the saddest pink Floyd acid story ever.
Tell this Patel,
this pink Floyd as to it sounded epic cause this is how I found out about it.
I was on my message board and someone made a threat that Joe Diaz as an you fear
of dropping acid and go and see pink Floyd.
I'm like,
God damn,
those motherfuckers are doing it.
I felt like,
I was like,
when you hear about one of your friends,
it's about to go trip.
It's like your friend is really literally about to get in a boat and go sale to
their side of the world.
It really feels the same way.
I'll have a good time with that.
Like Eddie called me up once.
He goes,
dude,
I'm doing five grams of mushrooms tonight.
Graham was like,
Oh shit.
All right,
man.
Good luck.
Good luck,
dude.
Tell me,
tell me everything.
Tell me everything.
I'm like,
write shit down.
Write shit down.
Tell me everything.
Good luck.
It's so weird that Eddie's the guy that when you used to do mushrooms younger
that he's like,
yeah,
dude,
I'm doing five grams.
You're like,
why is that guy doing?
No,
no,
no.
That's not what it is at all.
Brian [inaudible] depends on how you're using mushrooms.
He's built up a tolerance to,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Your tolerance goes away.
If you just stop for a couple of weeks,
you with,
with mushrooms,
the big,
big doses,
like five grams,
six grams,
seven grams.
Those are the ones where the people have these insane transcended experiences
where they talk about communicating with some alien lifeforms and being taken
aboard ships and being traveled to other dimensions and you know the secrets of
the universe bestowed upon you.
I mean,
that's where like Terrence Mckenna came up with TimeWave zero novelty theory
based on the East Ching,
tons of mushrooms,
two buckets of B 12 you're going to trip and Brian,
Brian [inaudible],
listen,
these are some of the most powerful experiences that people have ever had.
You're just thinking of mushrooms is a silly thing.
I never liked these guys talking about grammar mushrooms.
I'm tripping my ass off and I don't say go far.
There's not the same.
It's not the same three grams.
And what?
Smoke Pot.
It's a different fucking experience.
Like the Jim Morrison seen the doors when he's out in the jungle,
but I've also eaten regular acid.
That's been,
was that,
no,
no.
That's another thing.
I've also done acid where it's taken you,
you know,
it's an eight hour fucking trip.
You go up levels and different emotions,
man.
After you know,
you do a thousand of those mushrooms,
they go three,
four hours and at least in Tet I've taken some fucking ass that you know,
you just keep going in and out and you're living off your subtext.
Your subutex is which fuel in you.
You've seen something,
but your subutex is taking you somewhere else.
So you're thinking about why you didn't clean your room when you were fucking
six.
But I'm talking to this,
you know,
it's amazing.
I had a wish smuggled guy.
I had to bring mushrooms and wants to Jersey and when I brought him to my
friend's house,
I put them on top of the table.
His name was Danny beyond cooler and we left and his younger brother came home
and started eating them.
Oh,
he thought they were like French fries and we're hearing now and he's like,
the fucking shrooms.
That's my brother.
Oh brother was like 10 or 11 his mother fuck ate half the bag.
We were skating to take them to the hospital.
So we just left them there.
We went out.
This is so serious.
This is scary.
This is,
but you don't know this family,
this family,
the mother shot at him with a gun one time.
Danny was the kid that I was at his house and he would be doing a line of coke
while his mother was shooting steroids and his fucking Hash.
Do you know what that's likable?
His what?
His mother would shoot her with Deca once a day.
His mother would shit on the phone.
This was this house.
He'd be beyond the phone snorting a line of coke in front of his mother when his
mother putting a syringe in his that this is this house.
Really,
this kid being tan and eat a half ounce of mushrooms.
The shit the mother shot at him one time when that kid go,
one that ate the mushrooms,
listen to what he's saying is that he probably made grams.
I brought him 14 he prolly ain't five or six and we got the stomach.
I just looked at it but let's go in.
This kid did years later.
Let me tell you how smart that acid made them years later.
That kid's doing 20 years right now for what?
For robbing a bank with a fish,
with a fish hook down at night,
deposit money out of the fucking thing like dirty large out of a back into the
cab to fucking New York and to get a flight to Hawaii.
And you know how they caught him cause he gave the cab drive a hundred dollar
bill.
That's how they nailed the little beyond Coolo.
He's in Jersey.
He probably out by now,
but they nailed him robbing a bank with a fucking fishing line and a hook.
Do you feel responsible?
Maybe,
but fuck it.
He had a good time,
you know.
Well,
here's the funny thing.
He ate the mushrooms we went out to do,
I have a party.
We get back at three and he goes,
oh my God,
all the lights are out in the house.
He goes,
that's amazing.
Cause this guy's house was always rocking.
He had sisters that would party with drug dealers and the mother.
We walk in and all the lights were out.
We turned the lights on and the brothers in the living room,
the young ones sitting there by himself with little lights out.
He looks at us and he goes,
what?
I ain't tripping.
We just broke out,
broke.
Come fuck out.
We just grow.
God,
it's eight hours later,
right?
This little kid was in the living room just fucking slashed,
wet and profusely.
He had his shirt off.
He had the air on.
Oh,
it was fucking classic.
You can read that kid's mind and see what he saw at 10 years old.
Not knowing that.
That comment,
that taking that big boats coming.
Yeah.
Well I don't think it bodies.
I did ask it the first time when I was 13 I pay you right now.
I don't think I was prepared for it.
I did window paint with,
it was like hitting a fucking home run in my head.
You did what?
For her to show pain.
I've heard of so many dudes that did it real young and they just fucked their
brain.
Come back.
I'm very lucky than shot that shit.
I was by a hundred hits for $90 and sell it for $3 high school and I would take
three or four of them in two or three days.
You know what I'm saying?
It's got the three days.
You fucking think it's going to stem.
You can feel your stem when you wake up in the morning.
The back barely wrecks your ass.
Oh my God.
I just had it in there.
I was like electro man,
I just had in the back of my neck.
You know what's the most important thing you ever figured out when you were on
drugs when I was on acid is a motherfucker cause it lets you go out and look at,
you know what I'm saying?
And that's why I want to see a pink Floyd again.
Cause I seen him the first time they came in.
When you go see those motherfuckers,
I mean I went to the gym this morning,
I was listening to them again.
Uh,
uh,
welcome to the machine or something and one of those from wish you were here.
Woke up my son to the machine,
whatever.
And those motherfuckers tripped and then they wrote about it,
which is really brilliant in a musical way.
So that's why I was so fired up about this.
But when you sit there and it just takes you from one emotion to the other,
when I tripped,
I want to be Martin Sheen and apocalypse now,
that'll be gone.
That's it John.
When he goes,
he's fighting with the wind.
All that scene where he's tripping.
He bangs the fucking mirror and he's naked.
That's a trip.
That's the best fucking trip you'll see.
And the other thing was we,
we got together,
you know,
the other day we took the acid.
Yeah,
we took a half a hit.
Then we got on the train and then we took another hit on the train.
And when we got there we walked over to staples.
Why'd what?
Tell me the thought process.
You took one,
you waited and pop it skin popping,
popping.
The heroin people would do,
they always pop a little bit in this again,
just to see how strong the heroine is.
You want to test them.
Motherfuckers want them skin pop parents.
It's like waiting.
It's an expression,
a half a joint test.
The waiting time,
if I give you a bag of weed and you just,
instead of rolling the big blunt,
you're like,
hold on,
this is Joey.
D is,
let's just take one fucking hit you following me.
So we took a half a hit at four 30 just to time it out.
And then we took the other hole hit at six o'clock the time it out.
So I figured by eight o'clock I'd be in fucking Jupiter.
But instead we were outside trying to get tickets.
When we pulled up,
they had tickets for a buck and a quarter,
but on the left hand side all the way on the left,
we wouldn't have seen that.
I wouldn't have mind going and to get those tickets.
But we took a gamble.
We thought we'd get something else,
but there was no scalp done.
Donna and then I wanted to stay in fight,
but it wasn't the applying till.
I thought I would see in a pink Floyd closet my trip that night while I was
there,
my,
because the acid didn't hit me on the train ride till we went to eat something
and that's how I knew it was good acid because I was tripping.
But we ate something.
Once we went through that fucking restaurant,
the stable,
whatever the fuck,
the name of the Pantry,
the Pantry,
that's when they kicked in.
That's when it kicked in.
We'd walked away.
It's probably eight 35 and 40 so how strong is that?
It's my judgment.
It's like I got to pop two of them to really get the party store on an empty
stomach,
two of them and get into some excitement.
That's all I got.
I still got them.
I got them.
I feel like coming,
starting to kick in,
but then it would just wouldn't click.
It didn't go over the mountain and I think we had to get into some type of
devious on a tricky thing though about acid.
You don't know how God stronger.
That's why the test the wall,
it does this thing to work comes and then goes away,
comes stronger and then goes away.
It goes away.
You smoke a joint and it comes all the way up minute.
I've had a bunch of people tell me that eating weed is a lot like LSD.
Is that the case?
No.
No,
not even close.
Not even close.
What is,
what is the difference,
Brian?
LSD.
If it's good LSD like Jesus.
We used to take Jesus Christ or Beavis and butthead acid back in the day.
That was like the big ones,
right?
It used to actually take like,
like be a DMT trip,
different rural,
you're not,
this is not your room anymore.
This is a roommate of Jello for three hours.
Like and then next thing you know your hands are you know,
falling on the floor and you're like,
it's like in the very beginning it felt like you're on an edible or 10 minutes
after I had it I was like,
oh my body can't fuck him.
I think it's got the intense part or the body like you're feeling I know intent
or you know tighten up like the strict nine type feel.
I think it has this couldn't have strychnine in it.
It didn't have straight tracks.
Why you saying strychnine those this trick inside the street?
Yeah,
the old days.
Why would they book strictly on the back in the day they used to say it made it
stick to the paper more or something like weird like that.
I don't know if that was
and the next day you're back you felt like a fucking Milo and there used to be
things like if you got in a car accident that strychnine if it hits you right in
the back,
you're foot furlough,
there's behind that you're going to go into your system.
Exactly.
But yeah,
that's why.
Then I switched to doing liquid on sugar cubes where you just buy a big thing,
a sugar cubes and just buy some liquor.
That was awesome.
The liquid from a mad scientist who knows you have a drawing or something,
you got to drop her gate to.
The Dea keeps a very close track of the precursors,
the stuff that you need to chemically synthesize
LSD.
Well,
I'll tell you what actually is really,
I could have gone,
I could've got the liquid for this show,
but he wanted 600 the canister and they wanted to mail it to me.
Oh No.
Sorry.
By won't tell you what they want to put you in jail.
No,
no.
This is my buddy I know of a long time,
but just the male thought,
I don't want somebody knocking on the door and I got fucked a spike TV in front
of my door with a camera and the DEA show on there.
You them.
Yeah.
If I,
if I know the guy on this cut,
I get it from my home 20 you don't need that much anyway going,
well you need two drops quick.
You just can't call whatever.
And Sandy two drops flows to me.
They want you to buy the whole fucking container and I didn't mind buying a
container,
but then they got to contain in my house and liquid others d you know,
two in the afternoon.
I'm bored.
Ain't nothing going on.
You're just kicking.
It's a bad idea.
Yeah.
You find all the time.
I don't give a fuck.
Do a weird thing.
Worried about being set up.
You know,
it's a weird thing with,
with drugs,
with certain drugs,
like you have to worry about being set up.
It seems so lame.
If you're a guy's like into coke,
especially if you sell coke.
Man,
I know a guy who is just selling a little bit of coke.
He was not selling a lot of coke.
Who's selling it?
Like at clubs in here and there just,
you just always still like to make a little extra money.
And He,
his supplier got in trouble and he got arrested and apparently he likes
swallowed the Baggie or something.
He got off and he never had to do time,
but they were after him and they were on to him.
I don't remember who fucking told me his story,
but um,
so what happened was they,
what they did was they set him up and they said that they were going to have
this,
his supplier got popped.
So the DEA went behind his supply and they said,
listen,
this guy that got off,
we're going to go get him.
Okay,
you're going to help us get him and we're going to give you some time off.
So what they did was they set it up.
So they went after the little guy who was like selling a little bit here and
there,
and he said,
hey man,
I'm going out of business.
You can take my whole supply.
I'll give you fucking half off.
I'm going to give you half of what I paid for it.
I just want out.
You can take the whole thing,
but I need it all in cash.
Scott goes,
okay,
so this dummy goes and gets it all in cash,
gets this big wad of cash,
meets him hurt,
rip Swat guys show up a humongous amount of,
talked him into becoming a major dealer.
They talked him into this.
So now the guy goes away forever.
I got were 15 years or something crazy.
And meanwhile what he was,
he was just such a petty little drug dealer and he got fucked.
Well,
little amounts seat,
you know,
Amen.
And Graham and eight ball on you and see if you have an eight ball.
It's not packaged up.
You're okay from my head.
But one of my point was,
what?
How crazy is that?
They can do that.
They can set you up with a fake.
They can make the number,
they can say,
you know,
it's a,
it's a $500,000 or you know,
$1 million worth of coke.
They could bring the coke,
they can set you up like it doesn't have to be anything.
That was your idea.
It could be their idea,
which is not fair because if you're dealing with someone who's a criminal,
okay,
did the psychology behind a criminal is always,
this could be my last score.
This could be a big score.
Maybe I get this and I get out,
you know,
maybe I get this and I'll do something legit.
Like it's so tempting for them.
If they'd done criminal shit before and they've got away with it,
you come to them with some crazy crap that's like you,
like you know some really,
some guy was trying to be faithful and some chick shows up naked in his house,
sucks his deck and says,
ah Ha,
look what you did.
Yeah,
and it's like,
that's not normal.
Suck my Dick.
Are you freaking out?
I said,
I don't know what it is.
What happens is what happens is this the guy who rolled against them,
even if we went to the government still this motherfucker's smart.
He has to take it to trial.
If you had a half a million dollars to pay for go.
He's got a ton of money to pay for an attorney.
Nobody wants to put a snitch on the witness stand so they plea bargain him out
in the,
you know there's three fucking years because if you get go away that way,
that's the other angle.
They lie to you and your case though,
they keep rolling want,
but if they want to get you,
how did they get you?
They got you to this guy named Joe Rogan.
I type it up.
Joe Rogan's got more arrested.
My client,
I want to see this guy in court.
I want to see him testify.
Let's take it to trial.
Fucking let's take it route.
Fuck it.
Let's take it to trial.
This guy goes in the stand.
You've been arrested for everything from as mothers to smoke and fucking 20
joints at school and you're going to come testify.
My,
my God,
they throw the fucking thing up.
Caught that coercion shit is kind of fun.
Well,
it's tricky,
but that's actually true.
How could they do that?
How can they come them up with this?
Whatever the fuck they want and trust to what's important.
You're on trap and trap.
It is,
but I don't think it is.
I think as long as you are,
you've already been dealing with that guy and it's like it's a normal situation.
Like are they said some old lady's a cop down the street with a bag at somebody
robs or you know,
but she's really a cup.
It's like that's not to trap.
[inaudible] always walked down here all the time.
That's a very good point.
Yeah.
No,
that sounded trap meant at all.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's an undercover cop.
Yeah.
I said it's a weird thing where they're allowed to come up with scenarios,
you know,
they're allowed to do this shit.
Listen,
one thing,
and you know this thing could come into your house anytime.
What are the fucking store?
They do it everywhere.
They don't just do it.
I mean they do Seiberling they do torrents.
They'll throw fucking tron on there to see if you download tron and then,
you know,
get you for that too.
I did download tron arrested.
Did you like that shit?
Oh,
sorry.
It's amazing.
You'd be surprised.
You'd be surprised with nothing to cover.
Listen,
let me tell you something.
For an undercover cop to buy coke from somebody,
they got to do coke in front of.
That's just now.
Yeah.
You have to,
these kind of,
a lot of those guys get hooked.
They get hooked.
No will.
The most important thing is they buy the coke from you.
They do a line from the,
and they pushed the trial back to nine months.
By the time the cop goes into trial,
he's clean and salts out of assistance out of his system.
Right,
right.
It's not,
it's your word against yours.
They'd do what the fuck they want.
If they want to come after you.
It's like just gotta be very man.
You just got to be under the radar.
Listen to kid came to visit me two weeks ago,
three weeks ago from Jersey.
We didn't get the hookup.
This kid's been dealing blow since we were in high school.
He's got a plumbing business.
He's got three different ex wives with three houses in three different Robson
and a Cherry Hill,
New Jersey.
He's got six employees,
he's got bids all over and he's filled Hogan.
He's got a broad,
he a Russian brought here,
the Strip club,
you understand me?
[inaudible] 47 voting age three kids,
three different bronze you child support,
but the sell and blow since eight balls since we've,
while he just know how the fuck did you do that often knows.
Not a lot of guys who can do that.
Almost all of them get busted.
The odds are against you.
If you go on good,
there's a way to go and stay on
done.
You must finance,
you know you can find it and you know when you're financing a good thing and you
get 20% of their action and then make an 800,000 a month,
that's not too fucking shabby,
you know?
Yeah.
But you figure somebody who come after him.
I mean it's just amazing.
And he took half the dough and started up a business.
You got six Bucklin blowers with trucks and walking the Balkans.
Louise,
what's his job?
What did we do?
Well,
you don't want to say no,
but it's just amazing that some people,
we had this,
we had this kind of,
you know,
some people go away and some people are very smart,
some people stupid about it.
I always thought it was bad luck no matter what.
I always thought somewhere along the line you're going to pay for it.
You know,
three fucking lies.
He's got three ex wives.
That alone psychologically is bullshit on somebody.
Everybody that I've ever met that sellouts fucked up sometimes become fucked up
and the calm is horrible.
They're always,
they're always sketchy to be around.
They're always late for it.
Don't you put on is worried about somebody robbing them?
Cops catch what's the most interesting [inaudible] I don't watch a lot of drug
drug,
drug documentaries and all that shit because people always try to be bigger.
But I didn't watch a very interesting one where they took a rocker out of
England.
It took them to Columbia and showed them what it takes to make a kilo of cocaine
from scratch.
And they took this motherfucker in the bunker with machine.
Whoa.
And this motherfucker was breaking down.
I'm never,
that's the fucking,
never did another line again.
Why He came box spreading the gospel that way.
How what it takes to fucking get that gram of coke,
what you're really doing to society,
what you're really doing to these people some way you've got to pay.
Look at this whole war now is about heroin.
You and I both know it.
Go to a big chunk of what this was about and no one wants to mention,
nobody wants to pay.
It sounds like you're a wacky conspiracy theorist,
but here's the bottom line folks.
90 plus percent of the world's heroin comes from Afghanistan.
That is a multi multibillion dollar business.
And if you think these fucking industrialists cock suckers that are running the
world,
they're going to leave that money behind your fucking crane.
90% they've got army,
fucking a United States army troops guarding poppy fields.
Wow.
And it's still coming in.
It's still coming.
It's coming in like crazy.
They're helping these people grow it.
So the Dell get dust to the Taliban.
We have to gain their trust.
Geraldo Rivera.
We talked about this a couple of weeks ago on the podcast or last week there.
It's,
it's,
it's real proven shit that's going down.
There's fucking so much heroin there.
I mean,
it's incredible.
The fucking guy who is in the,
we talked about this last week as well,
but just because you guys are here,
the president of CIA,
his brother or the president of Afghanistan brother,
his brother was an employee of the CIA and his brother was a known heroine
dealer.
His brother was selling heroin and getting paid by the CIA.
This the fucking brother of the president of Afghanistan.
If you don't think that there's something going on,
you're crazy.
Why would they leave that money?
The fact that they're willing to kill people,
which we know they are from money,
we know that they're willing to go to war with countries that probably do shit
and they have,
there's nothing to gain.
They're for America for freedom or for fucking safety.
It's just cause there's something there that they want.
So now someone else's or control is getting them instead of somebody in
Afghanistan getting the money,
we're getting it.
Who knows?
I don't know.
We've gotta be partners.
Someone was standing over there for free medical stands up here where the United
States like toilet.
That garden is such a big lie that you even just talking about it,
we sound like idiots.
That's the amazing thing about the idea that the government is sold drugs.
It's such a big lie.
It's so crazy that it just bringing it up and you're like,
listen to this crazy idiot saying that the government is sold drugs and I'm not
necessarily against selling drugs.
You know,
I'm not,
I don't need,
I'm thinking,
fuck,
you could sell bullets.
Why can't you sell drugs?
I'm not afraid of you selling bullets.
I think you should be allowed to sell bullets.
I believe in all that stuff.
I mean,
I think we definitely need law enforcement need to protect ourselves when people
that abuse shit and set up laws and be very strict about shit like that.
But I'm not for fucking controlling too much shit,
man.
So I'm not scared of anybody selling drugs or socialist.
Not really use,
it's more libertarian type comma socials.
I think I'll just be legal.
Even the ones I won't do,
but that's not socialists socialists as someone that thinks that all the wealth
should be evenly distributed as well.
You're just a communist
rugs and I think that is the most dangerous fucking thing ever.
I couldn't imagine somebody in the car next to me coked up or somebody on
heroin.
I just couldn't imagine say that.
But it's been proven in other countries that it actually lowers the addiction
rates,
lowers the rates of use in,
in Portugal,
they had no drug laws in Portugal for a while.
They made everything legal.
It decriminalized everything and people have been doing it left and right.
And by the way,
that's gone on in Mexico as well as zoning laws.
I don't know why you wanna build there.
No,
I'm saying sell drugs like right next to a school and stuff or they probably
have some sort of restrictions.
I don't know.
I think with decriminalizing means is that it's okay to have it,
but you're not supposed to be selling it.
That selling it.
It can be criminal,
but if you have it then it's okay.
How are you supposed to get it?
Well,
this is the ideas that you're not supposed to benefit or profit from other
people being addicted to something that's dangerous.
So you could do dangerous things if you want to on your own accord,
figure out how to do it.
But if you start selling it,
that's when you're,
that's when you in trouble,
which would make sense to me because that's like sort of,
it's like sort of saying you should have personal freedom,
but the other person should not be doing something damaging to society willingly
and knowingly.
And if you're selling heroin,
you're doing something damaging to society willingly and knowingly.
So you want it.
Yeah,
you can still get it though.
You just don't have to,
you just don't sell it.
See,
look at the beautiful thing about drugs.
Here's the great thing about drugs.
Almost all the good ones,
people are willing to give you.
You know?
That's,
that's really how it should be.
The coolest thing about weed and P and potheads.
The number one thing I said,
everyone's so generous like pods are always giving you,
here's a cookie,
dude,
have this breast trip you want to join.
Here's this dude's smugglers who wants some.
It's always like everyone that's part of the whole week.
Nobody giving,
you know,
coke rocks a good healthy drug.
Did healthy drug is district three positive things people give me Joan in
mushrooms,
people will give you my,
she will give you the notion that people come to me,
give me mushrooms after shows.
I've never taken them.
I don't know what the fuck kind of this one dude just gave me mushrooms wants in
San Francisco and it was just weird,
creepy dude.
It was just sweat a little bit too much.
Just thinking probably about me taking these things and dying and I was like,
get the fuck Outta here bitch.
I taking your crazy mushrooms,
you motherfucker.
But my point is that any drug good enough to be taken should be free.
You should be vulnerable.
If you can't figure out a way enough pot for free,
why not buy the seeds by the,
by the fucking the shit grow.
Can you go heroin herself now it's much more difficult.
So really you don't have to go to another climate.
I don't think you can grow heroin in this climate.
I think that's one of the things to the box.
I don't know
what Brian.
Um,
I think uh,
cocaine is that way too.
You can't grow up cocaine in the United States.
You can't be grown here.
Is that a mountain thing too?
Because I know that the mountains,
they take it well,
most people find it very,
very useful though the actual leaves,
like coca leaves are actually healthier than coffee and these people just chew
the leaves and they,
you know,
they're shepherds and out there in the fucking mountains and shit and there's
such a high altitude,
it gives them energy.
Huh.
So it's actually like a beneficial plant.
Yeah.
It's just when you get processed with the money,
yeah.
You process it and synthesize it and break it down.
That's when it's like,
whoa.
Fucking central nervous system.
And then what I understand is the real big problem is what they mix it with.
Right?
Right now,
especially now,
I have watched a thing on 60 minutes like a year ago and it's just bad.
It's coming into the country in batches and all these people last year was in
the Seattle area really bad.
Did you tell me that you've gotten some that had gasoline in it somehow?
Will.
The most important thing is that it's not getting out of the country is getting
the ether alcohol into Columbia to wash away when you would get the cocaine with
the eighth if anybody watches,
that's a cocaine that people dream about.
It goes down like bubblegum via you keep snowing it all my cause it tastes
great.
Rockstar cocaine's rock star,
shit dead.
What happened was they couldn't get enough ether so they started cooking it with
gasoline and Turpentine.
You snorting this shit that smells like cat piss,
but it's four in the morning and you don't give a fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
Then the next day get nose is red.
The ae your,
those has a disintegrated from textbook general
but it's just,
it's just that the addiction but the gasoline.
So what they would do was you get the gasoline base to make crack because nobody
really cares about faced if you're smoking crack.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So then they get the good shit to sell the stuff for that.
Ethan,
I told you we were talking about this before we started the podcast.
I stopped smoking out of pipes because I think when you use a lighter,
I taste that shit.
I taste that lighter fluid that sits nasty.
But thinking about the gasoline,
you snore.
Yeah.
When I started using the vaporizers and when I start smoking joints,
I started realizing like this tastes better.
Just doesn't taste all fucked up.
You know?
Ideally I think you should light
a joint with a match.
That's probably the way to go.
You know?
Because even when you let it show me that even good.
It's a match.
Yeah.
Cause I got that liquid salt winter.
We have you ever heard how you should never light something off a a candle
because supposedly the little micro candle shit,
we'll get into your lungs wax and yet I always wonder if that was a wipey you
can get hit the lie that touch a cigarette to a candle wants in the west and
just,
I still smoked it,
but it took so long as folksy.
That's gotta be bad,
right?
Oh,
do you smoke some wax?
You're fucked.
[inaudible] SAS spoke works,
but yeah,
you promise you let a joint then that's a whole joint you have lit.
Yeah.
That's all a commitment.
Yeah,
but I pushed it out.
I just pinch it out whenever it's done.
You know when I'm done,
I just break it off and then you've got a roach.
I like it better,
man.
I think that fucking those pipes are bad for your lungs,
I think they'll cigarette lighters constantly breeding that she did.
I can taste it sometimes.
I'm like,
that ain't good.
That's my doctor said you use a vaporizer.
I love.
Yeah,
take a nice bug.
You cut it with a scissor.
Nice.
You take a paper and a half of that zigzag,
you put that mother fucker together.
Edge,
right?
Like a doctor.
You flipped that mother fucker put it in their role.
That mother fuck up and let that thing dry.
And when you lie,
did you hear that thing go from all the shit burning inside and that first to
hit that goal on why you exhale and you think on a fucking twice cooked pork.
You know what I'm saying?
That's how you roll.
I love that.
That's the original.
To me that's,
there's no better system than that.
Take your bomb vaporizer.
I'm going to live down 90 fuck you.
There's no better way than a paper and a half that motherfucker down and blast
off the shirt.
The buddy of mine gave me look at this chick rolling a joint.
Yeah,
very.
There's like there's a ritual to that.
You don't think about it.
Yeah,
you don't pull it like lighting a bomb something and hopefully it's a chicken
man.
Cause that would make feminine care.
Did I let a lady boy role,
my job is using a dollar bill and Ken let up.
I ain't scared you
set.
I'm not scared.
Lady boys can roll my jaw.
I give them hugs.
I love all that.
Feel those weird hard tits.
You ever give a dude who's trying to be a girl,
a hug and you feel the hard tits?
They have hard tests.
I have not so sad.
Yeah.
We had a couple on the dance show them and give them out to give you a hug and
they their,
their tits are hard as a rock.
It's like they're punching you in the chest.
The transvestites sexuals transsexuals when they're actually going through that.
We had a couple of them on the man show.
Really cool one school.
One of them was fucking coolest shit.
What's her name?
Gea.
Is that what it was?
I don't know.
I think it was,
I forgot what her name is.
She was super,
super cool,
like a really fun person because she was a man that became a woman.
Got All snippy,
snippy son,
son.
I don't know if she had gotten snippy or she was going to get snippy.
Very nice person.
Anyway,
she,
she'd give us,
she was in mother,
the,
uh,
sketches where,
Doug get to hook her and she's,
uh,
she has to go to the bathroom.
And while she's a,
Doug looks in on her while she's in the bathroom and she's standing up and
pissing in the toilet
and talk,
starts to Sobrato goes,
hey,
wait a minute.
What she,
you know,
she really did piss in the toilet standing up.
So I guess she does have a deck,
but,
um,
it was,
uh,
she gives you a hug,
you know,
all,
thank you very much.
We had a great time.
And when you're,
you're feeling when you hug them,
you can,
their nipples.
No,
the whole tit.
It's like,
it's all fake.
You know what I mean?
They don't have any breast tissue to work with.
Like if a woman gets breast augmentation,
she might have a BEACOPP she gets it pumped up to a c and still,
it feels like a breast for a man.
It's really just muscle tissue and a bag of water.
You know,
it's fucking strange.
If comedy would want it for a year and a half in Seattle.
Redall with a transactional on sexual.
She looked like that fucking thing like doing.
She had a head and she put a wig on and we send go like we go read it,
you want to drink and should we give her like a 20 she'd go and volume and we
rob approach.
You've got value.
It's rude little pills that she come back and we need to have pizza and she'd
have a woman's voice.
When when she yelled at us you'd go back to a management,
put it down.
It was fucking amazing.
You know she died.
She hit her head.
She went out dancing one night.
The head was big and the equilibrium,
that's a true story.
Really equal liberty with the head.
They left the head still really fucking big like a man size had,
oh my God.
How do you somebody the head and she fell off the stage.
What the head,
cause her head was too big of your body shrank like hands.
Bali shrank up.
So the head was too big.
Shoes and big bobble bobblehead.
That's why she was taking all those pills.
She was taking like perk because her head was too big for all of us and she'd
fall all the time.
Could you imagine if your head was on like a little woman's body?
They've got a,
I forgot about saying be a fucking night.
That's what I want to lose that whole longer away and I was getting headaches
for a couple of days that I'm saying fucking body can't support your head.
You can't do it.
These people lose a bunch of weight and all suddenly got this fucking ginormous.
Ed had so trail looking at them and they don't understand that fucking head is
huge and Jenny Craig,
Nolan got none for your fucking head.
Nobody died.
Nobody got none for that.
What happens is your head developed a size 400 pounds about Ralphie.
How about Ralphy?
Ralphy.
She's had a long way to bucket of 50 and look at his hands got away up.
Fuck.
It's fucking giant.
Like my head.
It's fucking huge.
That's a weird thing.
When you gain weight or going one weightlifters gain weight to your head,
gets bigger.
Your fucking chickens.
One Yard.
You should see my helmet.
You should see the of check answer.
He was out of order it special.
I had to go like fucking NFL Europe.
Only people bought up in New Jersey and the of Europe have heads this fucking
big.
You follow me?
It's funny because we were talking about this last night about someone in a
Jujitsu class was talking about chicks who are bodybuilders.
They they get in large clitorises cause they just take massive amounts of
testosterone so high and they're their dicks grow.
Well,
you know they're,
they're,
yeah,
they grow a clit.
Their clit actually becomes like a small deck.
This is super sensitive.
I don't know.
It must be super easy to find a piece of Calamata at tough shit that they sell.
Like now I'll be in route column on a Thursday night.
The regular
cooking,
that's all tougher pod.
I've had it before when Lena got hard fucking clicks.
When you go down to the girl and you see a ring there,
a little piece of metal,
you're like,
oh Jesus,
anybody can hang out here.
You letting people fucking staple like metal in here parking.
Fucking this ain't a special place to be.
You've got to clip ring down there.
Hooker.
Not only that,
what am I going to do to you?
I'm going to damage you.
You're,
you're willingly getting metal shoved through your pussy and crazy horse.
But they um,
these,
um,
these bodybuilders that grow,
grow a click,
I don't think it's as big a deal.
I don't think they get as big a dose is when they're trying to turn a woman into
a man.
Cause when they turn a woman into a man,
I think they give them massive doses more even probably than bodybuilders.
This is just not lifting weights and sins.
Peaches grow beards.
Whoa.
Yeah,
they grow beards,
man.
That's one of the,
the,
the weirdest thing about the,
the transsexual female to male,
they grow beards.
Man.
They started growing facial hair and shit.
That's it.
Was it
the best part is the end.
Uh,
the crazy thing,
if you think about going to believe me as some dude with a wig and a black eyes,
right?
Science,
there's probably a connection with girls that have bigger pussy boners and they
have facial hairs.
I bet you have some kind of clinical for any facial hair.
I think it's probably related to that.
You see like a really brawny looking woman.
There's some,
some women,
especially when they get older.
That's the other thing about women.
When they get older,
they start,
their body produces more testosterone and guys err the exact opposite.
They start producing more.
Yes.
For Estrogen,
I think it's probably because at the women have to fight for their fucking life.
Once in the old days they became useless when they couldn't have children
anymore.
Once they hit men and some women do.
Yeah.
There's a lot of controversy with that though,
Huh?
Oh,
you're fucking with the balance of hormones and you know,
it has to be done right.
You got to test your blood all the time.
It's,
it's very tricky.
Yeah.
You know,
a lot of people just want to take pills and everything's going to be grooving,
you know?
Oh Man.
I think eventually what they're going to figure out how to do is keep all your
hormone levels exactly the same for the rest of your life and it's going to be
weird.
It's like,
then we get to find out like what makes your body deteriorate?
Is it hormones?
Is it genetics?
Is it,
you know,
just some stuff inside your,
your genome.
And it starts to fail.
Like how,
how much can we stop that in our lifetime?
We might see people live to be hundred 5,200 years old in our lifetime.
This might be the first lifetime where we'll look.
It's a restaurant alone.
I keep an eye on that Monday.
Fucking stop was dope.
He's my canary in a coal mine.
Oh,
obsessed captain plastics.
So 64 years old.
He swole like our motherfucker,
but he's cutting the shit out and shooting stuff in some way.
You got to pay for it.
I know.
I'm sure.
I just want to see how long you live.
This is fascinating.
Twins.
Let's say you're abroad and you want to become a man and they give you all this,
uh,
testosterone.
Oh middle.
They take it home and stick.
Come on now you grow.
Dick just becomes one just of a,
yes.
The clit is very similar.
It's very to a penis.
And as your,
your um,
click tourists getting gorge with testosterone as your body becomes a gorgeous
testosterone,
there's shooting it like I'm get,
I'm guessing that it has to be big numbers because the one they had like private
Dick's,
it was a show,
I think it was called on Hbo.
It was all about dicks.
And they had this one woman who was a,
a,
a woman who was turning into a man and she said that it hurt her.
Dick is about the size of a thumb,
which is bigger than any like bodybuilder girl club I've ever seen on the inner
size of a thumb.
A thumb.
That's what she said.
And she says he gets rock hard.
And it was fascinating too to hear her talk about how she thought she knew what
it was like to be a man until they started shooting up your testosterone.
And she's like,
wow,
you know,
one of the things she was talking about was um,
when you have a raging hard on like how little in control you really are.
She goes,
I had no idea.
But when you would,
they interviewed her and they were talking about she got a boner and was like,
well cause your clip gets hard at how obsessive she was would just fucking,
she said,
you know,
primal and she was talking about how a guy with a raging hard on,
it's just not going to listen.
Like they just want to fuck,
you know,
that's like,
it's like it takes over like certain areas of your brain.
She didn't know like really you could have taken over like that.
It's a very interesting thing.
You know,
I,
I wouldn't want to be a woman,
but I would fucking,
if we could like switch,
if you could like enter into a woman's brain for a few hours and wander around
and see what it's like,
you know,
say all right.
It's like,
you know,
you're going to do mushrooms for a few hours or I'm going to take a pill,
I'm going to be a woman for a few hours.
I'm going to feel what that feels like.
That's gotta be so strange there.
They're balanced,
they're whole balance of life is so different than ours.
Everything about it.
And I think it takes us until like,
we're like much,
much,
much older to you data,
bunch of different chicks until you,
you know,
you see a bunch of different old women are kind of cool and you know,
you try to get together like a kind of sense of what it is to be a woman,
but they're like a totally different species than iceman.
There are totally different species that we live side to side with.
You know,
we don't have a fucking clue as to how they feel and they don't have a fucking
clue as to how we feel,
but we want to fuck them.
And because of that they want us to be a certain way.
And that's one of the problems in this country.
One of the problems in this country is it's difficult to get laid and a lot of
guys decide to change who they are because they want a woman to like them.
That's the pussification of America.
A big part of it is doing what the chick wants to do because you want to fuck
and they don't know what you're like.
They don't really understand what it is to be you.
They have no idea.
Like sometimes I'll get upset at something I met.
My wife just doesn't understand.
I'm like,
you don't understand because you're not a dude.
Okay.
If you're a dude you don't understand.
And I understand I don't understand shoes and now I understand bags.
The was that like an alternative comedy party when you're talking to a girl and
you're like arguing or something?
Yeah,
just in a normal way.
And some,
one of the little nerds comes over [inaudible] and talk to girls.
You don't realize I'm going to have sex with her later.
Yeah.
And you're,
you're plastering cock sucker.
You're trying to be the good guy side based on nothing.
Talking about that is the weakest shit ever.
I almost got in a fist fight with a guy in Manhattan who was a bartender around
the Oj trial.
You know,
there's this guy was the most self righteous con I think about guy still to this
day.
And all he was trying to do was impress the waitress man.
I was talking to the waitress and something came up about the Oj trial,
right.
And she said,
you know,
well Oj,
did that.
And he beat the shit out of his wife.
And I said,
well not necessarily.
I go,
I don't know exactly what it did do is I put,
they might've been like physical with each other.
Like I've had relations,
I've had friends who've had relationships where they,
their wife would hit them and they would,
you know,
fight back.
Like he would have to defend her and then the cops would come and then he would
get arrested with assault and battery.
I've,
I've known people where that's happened.
Why I said that and all I said was we'll all we know is that there was some sort
of restraining order and so the fucking bartender goes,
that's exactly right.
That's what you heard and that's what it is.
And the only way you get that one is if you abuse women.
And I was like,
Oh God,
are you fucking kidding me?
I go,
dude,
well all I'm saying is you weren't there and there could I?
I'm,
I'm pretty sure he probably killed his wife,
but I don't know.
You don't know either man.
You weren't there.
Like do you really know all of this is like while the case was going on while
the trial was going on before he was convicted,
this comes like ready to fight me are nowhere because he wanted to impress this
girl with how much he supports women and how much you like his defense.
Women's cheesy because nobody could sell it.
Don't go with guys at home.
This guy pointing and yelled at me.
I still remember him to this day.
I still remember him to this day cause I was like,
this is absurd.
Like this is the most ridiculous joke.
Like I don't need you.
I don't know you.
You don't know me.
I'm a nice guy and all of a sudden you're yelling at me because you think that I
support some guy beating the fuck out of his wife.
Like wow.
And all just to try to be captain here and he's trying to take,
push you into a corner where I am not with this at all.
I'm against this.
You're like,
I wasn't even saying I'm for.
Yeah,
exactly.
He's looking for a fight because why?
Because I was a comic and I was talking to the waitress and he was a bartender
and he probably wishes he was a comic book,
can't really pull it off.
Maybe he's acts and you know,
maybe models or whatever.
You would be just some New York douche bag.
And I just wanted to be like,
you know,
Captain Liberal,
save a hoe and jump in and look like a fucking superhero.
But the point is that shit only exists because we don't understand each other.
Oh,
if you could,
you could understand what it's like to be a chick man.
You would go,
oh,
all right.
If they can understand what it's like to be us,
they knew they would just kind of recognize like my dog and I'll try to stop my
dog from looking as balls because that's what he does.
Okay?
It was my,
my son,
and he's fingering his asshole and sucking on his fingers.
I'd be like,
Hey,
what the fuck,
dude,
this is crazy.
You got to go to a doctor.
You know,
but it's a dog.
I don't understand dogs,
man.
I just let it go.
And when girls get super dramatic over nothing,
you're like,
man,
that's who you are.
Just go,
whatever.
I'm gonna just tell you I love you.
Give me a hug.
Okay,
I'm gonna go watch TV.
Let's not get crazy.
I'm always going to be me.
You're always going to be you.
All right,
let's just figure this shit out.
You can't try to change me though.
You know how many dudes do you ever talk to where they say,
oh,
you like to do go,
but my wife does let me anymore.
What?
Your wife wants you to be a bitch.
Your wife wants you to be something you'd don't even you and I can't go to
Jujitsu and the Mormon wife doesn't let me.
Like,
what are you talking about?
You can't go to Jujitsu because your wife doesn't
let you.
What kind of a relationship do you have with your keeper?
Some weird person to hear that.
Yeah.
What does she do?
She gives you pussy and so you,
you,
you don't do your favorite things in life and your hobbies.
That's nonsense.
What kind of person would want you to,
could you imagine saying to a check a on what you do in Yoga anymore?
I think it's bullshit.
The yogas for fucking idiots.
Why?
What was the reasoning for not wanting to go through to Jitsu?
She didn't like him getting involved in like fighting and being around all those
guys and she's,
yeah,
she just thought that they had like bad attitudes and they were,
you know,
rough men.
Yeah.
She didn't want him being around rough men.
If she was like,
you hurt yourself,
you're gonna hurt yourself again.
I can't do this.
I don't know what it was.
But she put the Kibosh on it and you know,
you meet the guy and he's starts just like this shell of a man,
you know,
hanging around with this woman who probably doesn't even like the fuck anymore,
and she won't let him go to Jujitsu.
I gotta run it past my wife.
Ooh,
let me get back to you cause I got to run it past,
my wife had a guy in Dallas did.
He was one of these guys who would say,
settle on you and like do like that.
What?
I'd like to do some weed but my wife won't let me
do some weed.
And he was appointed one of those dudes.
I met one of those guys.
I ain't man,
I'm with you.
I want to you buddy.
He was out.
He would always point and say shit,
but I don't know if I'll never forget that dude wife will let me.
That's how I got my vaporizer.
Don.
Carlos and the Taco shop down there.
I guess I'm getting married.
She doesn't want me to,
whoa.
She said on the edibles and I was like,
that's,
that's hilarious.
So weird.
That's hilarious.
My wife gets weird.
She hasn't been with smoke weed in a long time because of a,
the babies because she had,
she basically went from one baby to the next,
you know,
and the ones,
two and a half years old.
And she was breastfeeding for a year and then right after that she was pregnant
again with another one.
So she hasn't had any weed in any of that time.
So like,
you know,
like just like little things.
She'll say,
she'll come home smelling like weed.
Is that when I smell,
I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
I was doing a,
I smoked constantly.
The fuck question is that,
don't you,
you try to pretend that I'm somebody.
I'm not,
because they want,
they want you to be,
you know,
hi honey,
I'm home.
I've got my briefcase and let me take off my loafers.
And it's also the children bring them around.
The chick can't motion should feel bad.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
it's not.
That feels bad.
No,
no,
no.
It's like this nesting in a baby protection.
She just doesn't want me to go crazy.
She doesn't want me to be a crazy person and wind up doing drugs.
I'm going to the Amazon way back in three months.
You should just know you have some person like your thinking about here,
how irresponsible I am.
How far are you crazy.
I am at,
I am the father of your children.
Okay.
Um,
um,
your,
you know,
I'm their daddy so I'm the one who has to be around and provide and keep a
stable life and raise them correctly and they're already swearing really where
the little one,
two and a half.
She says,
she says shit all the time.
Wow.
Like the other day I got a balloon format.
I was so pissed and the,
I forgot at the supermarket you so excited.
It was a princess balloon,
all these princesses on it and it was attached to a string and I pulled it out
of the trunk and that string unraveled and it flew away.
You.
It was
a helium balloon and I go,
dammit.
And she goes,
Dammit.
Like she immediately does what I do.
She's two and a half and the other day she was trying to get into this bouncy
thing that her little sister has all those little things he'd get in,
it's on springs and she can't get in.
So she got one foot in it.
She's going,
shit,
Shit.
Two and a half year old go shit.
I'm just glad it wasn't a balloon.
Not Joke.
Yeah,
she just looks at me.
I'm like,
the fuck.
That's what you're supposed to say.
What'd your foot gets stuck?
That's what you're supposed to sign.
She was,
you know,
she doesn't want me to swear on the kids.
It's not a good idea to swear around them.
Boat.
I mean I don't,
I don't,
I,
I really try to keep because I don't want them to have trouble with other kids
and I sweat in front of you.
Oh yeah.
Those fucking mind to mind.
My note not only didn't mind swear in front of me,
they never stopped me from swearing.
Never.
Like when people,
I would go over people's houses and Shit,
go over kids house would snap and I go off and mobile app to curse him out.
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
I would kill,
I was curse over people's houses and their parents would not want them hanging
out with him.
He never allowed to curse.
If kids cursing you guys.
Yeah,
they wouldn't do it.
I was raised,
I was raised like a wolf.
I was like left in the woods.
My parents were fucking,
I don't remember one piece of advice from my childhood,
not one,
not one.
And everyone was always allowed to swear.
You know,
my,
my stepfather was a big hippie and so because of that,
like,
you know,
he didn't like to put like borders and boundaries on shit.
So we'd go over people's houses.
I'm like,
this fucking show.
What are you watching this for?
And the parents would look at me and the mom would look at me like,
you know,
I did have me over for cookies and shit and hanging out with his kid.
I would sweat right in front of the parents.
I just wouldn't even think twice about it.
It was bearable.
No,
I'd be like,
what kind of fucking show is this?
Like
had a rabbi,
he pulled me aside once because the word suck.
Whoa.
I like that show sucks.
And he's like,
what?
Come here and didn't have a talk.
It's like,
why do you say things like that?
I'm like,
I don't,
I didn't realize there's a pad.
It's not cause what do you think that comes to my mind?
I don't know.
It just sucks.
What do you mean?
Yeah,
it sucks.
What?
I'm like,
I don't know what you're talking about.
It's crazy.
Like lava lamp in here.
[inaudible] about to join.
Exactly an hour ago.
So right now it's in full steam.
I've ever gone to some Cuban people's houses,
Lord as Nuñez.
Nice,
Nice Cuban people.
Lord is Ramos.
Nice,
decent.
You Walk in,
cross up there and the mother was fucking banging.
Really?
How is that going to the sixth grade?
The mother was bagging and as we were leaving,
I turned the Lord is Ron was his mother go,
hey,
you should get dressed up and maybe you should go out and get a little fucking
pop dogs the next day.
It's the lawyers came in and she goes,
you know how my fucking block,
nobody has ever talked to my mom like that.
Not even her husband,
her husband died.
And I told them,
mom,
you look in fucking good.
I was like,
in the sixth grade,
I was,
no,
you weren't allowed to say,
oh my mom.
You know?
So for you it was just being complimentary.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
as I was growing up,
my mom used to always say compliment women.
Let them know how beautiful they look like.
I remember one time she say to you though,
how did she react with the mother?
She was frozen.
So sixth grade is what,
how old is that?
13 1211 we were over there to go,
we want to go to a play.
And we all went over there and I'm looking at them the whole time.
This Cuban bitch.
Bang.
I didn't even hear my cock.
I just had the dick without not the head.
But you're already getting hired on.
Do you remember whether or not you guys are waking up with that hard dick?
I didn't get a head for,
I don't even have to have my legs.
I'm one of those people,
so I didn't get to 15 I'm have gorilla,
but I didn't have anti was weird that you don't have much Hampton people think
would think you.
Maybe you shave your arms knocked down.
You just don't appear.
I think rather didn't have hair on my dick.
I didn't take a shower with boys.
That was like 15 I'd be the one in the corner with a towel.
I had no hair,
no hair,
so I had no hair.
But I get so hot now and I told you this woods.
I said,
you're bagging bitch.
You should get dressed up and get some big,
this lady looked at me and throw you actually see Dick or is it Bingo?
Fuck yeah.
Really?
I could say it in Spanish.
In Spanish.
What's that?
Tell me how you would say to her in Spanish.
[inaudible]
that means that you're looking good.
Then [inaudible] just say it in the foyer.
It was going to get a deep [inaudible].
Oh God.
You guys like slang word for Pinger.
Pingers like modest Gabi.
I'm taking you over the top.
It's like jerking off the fucking loud.
Say That's like I,
this lady was like a Catholic Cuban.
I blew her fucking helmet right off with that.
That's my articles helmet.
What a,
what was crazy was in my house growing up.
That's bananas.
My mom and her girlfriends would talk about that crazy shit about eating pussy.
Really?
Your mom and her girlfriends were talking about when you play cards on Tuesday
nights and talking about eating post,
talking about eating pussy and when you get old on,
let me see your tongue quite that way.
You're talking,
I would show up by the fuck out of here when I was a kid.
My mom on Tuesday nights,
they get fucked up and then make me dance with like tiny.
Why these offer a bunch of women.
They put on La woman by the doors and I'd shake my hips and my mom would say
dollar Hmong,
which means give him him.
You know when you go like this and make it go back and forth and give them a
hand.
Give him how long and that's an expression.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
So when you you wear no underwear I guess?
No,
I had,
you know I was like five and six moms asking you to slap your dig back and
forth.
I give them a hand,
give them hand white,
give me booze and I pass out and I wake up the next fuck.
Yeah,
my mom was the shit like that photo that you had on your myspace page of you
when you were real young dancing.
Where's that fall happened at the house?
Is it on your myspace page still?
I think it's on my space kind of same that I don't have that picture and those
are like great picture that's you.
Like it's so funny because even though I can see that,
it's like what do you like 10 in the picture?
How old are the 10,
I could see it.
You,
I see your personality.
See the whole thing.
You as a kid and as Suzanne a suit.
Yeah.
And the funny thing was the rest of that,
um,
I'm making out with a girl and my 12th birthday,
my mom had a friend who were Puerto Ricans and they used to try to always hook
us up and shit.
He didn't even get laid to,
it was like 24 maybe take out of this wealth.
They made us take pictures like this,
what I had already like eating the pussy and shit and fuck them.
Before that we used to sleep over her house and we were kids.
She had hair on a Polisci tons of hay out.
She had to be a year or two older than me and our parents have trying to hook us
up.
So we got old and we fall in love.
So on the weekends I sleep on the couch and she's sleeping in the bedroom and I
go in there,
the middle to the Bronx and she'd show me a push,
you know,
pushing the next day I touch her stomach cause I told she was pregnant.
I would always think I got pregnant.
That's how fucking crazy
name was Yvette Rivera.
We just come inside.
If you're out there,
Facebook me,
you dirty freak Facebook because you're,
you are sucking Dick at 12 you were an animal now.
You know what I'm saying?
You got a fan with fucking metals on it.
You've probably done blowing you at 12 she didn't blow me at 12 she let me eat
her pussy and I think I remember like fucking them,
but then I would just pass out because when you're at 12 when you're fucking,
your central nervous system just gives out.
You just tap out,
you hear shit.
But you don't know what's happening in Asia.
You okay?
Yeah,
that's what it's like a doors movie they ask,
are you okay?
Yeah,
I'm okay.
You don't know.
Fucking call me once with my pants around my ankles.
I'm face down on the bed.
Uh,
and the swimsuit issue and the sports illustrated swimsuit issue at ACC right
above my head.
Just out past ass out.
Ah,
how old were you the first time you got to some
pussy actual pussy?
Yeah,
I was,
I think it was like 15 fooling around with the weirdest thing was when I was 13,
there was this chick who was 21.
She was a grown woman man,
a grown woman and she used to play softball with us.
This is when I lived in Jamaica Plain.
Jamaica plains,
a sketchy area.
Boston,
it's,
you know,
it's a lot of real poor people and people are fucking nuts.
And His broad,
um,
her name was Jeanette.
She had this boyfriend who was a construction worker and she was 21 man,
she was hot little piece ass and her construction worker boyfriend was out,
man.
And he's a hairy chested,
big fucking man.
And I would see this guy,
you know,
and the guy will be like working in the end.
I would think,
well you know this,
if this is her boyfriend,
you know that's a boyfriend.
Like you know the,
there's no way she'd be interested in me at 13 year old boy.
Like this is ridiculous.
I'm like a little child.
What was coming home from fucking playing softball somehow or another we all
wound cause we all would hang out on this one street that I lived on,
you know,
it was like a real neighborhood,
people would play stickball in the street and people would run around and play
hide and go seek and all kinds of crazy shit.
And a lot of young kids lived in this one area and it was pretty nuts.
She invites me over.
You want to listen to some pink Floyd?
Okay.
Yeah.
So we're listening to comfortably numb and all of a sudden she starts making out
with me.
Like I had never kissed a girl before ever.
So I went from no,
nothing,
no.
Never ever anywhere to all of a sudden this 21 year old is sucking my tongue and
she's grabbing my dick and I'm like,
whoa.
And I totally could not get it up.
Not even a little bit nervous.
Total panic total like what is happening?
Why is this woman kissing me?
Like what is going on?
And then we fooled around like a bunch of times more after that.
But there was never,
yeah,
it was never like sex.
I never fucked her pseudo.
It's just jerked my dick off and truck.
Wow.
So it wasn't until I was like,
I think I was 15 when my girlfriend was 14 which is crazy to think that people
fuck at 14 but she wasn't even a virgin.
Wow.
Eh.
She had fucked up mother guy
and she didn't want to admit it.
She would be like,
well,
we kind of did it sort of,
but not really do is be a rule girls always do that sort of didn't count.
Didn't like,
if a stranger to do to you,
would you count that as rape?
Right.
Good point.
Yeah.
Then that should count.
The rapist is going on,
just sticking in for half a stroke than leaving said no,
I didn't do it.
Well this girl,
I think she might've fucked my friend to the,
the first call I had sex with.
I think she might've fuck my friend cause she definitely made out with them
cause she was like with him first and then you know back then people are like,
Oh I don't like Bob Anymore.
I like Mike on Wendy's a bitch.
I'm tired of Wendy,
I'm going to,
you know this girl.
And I liked the people would like go back and forth,
you know,
no way fuck you were doing.
You were playing relationship.
You know the first relationships that I ever had.
Like you didn't know what the fuck to do.
He didn't know how to behave around them.
The whole thing was weird.
Like the get them stuff.
I don't know why or when.
Right.
And all I wanted to do once we started fucking what's fucked cause constantly
five times a day,
just,
just fuck everywhere.
I didn't do anything else.
I stopped working out.
I stopped playing sports.
I stopped doing everything from months.
It took like I had to go back to my taekwondo instructor.
He was yelling at me.
He was like,
well,
have you been,
I've been trying it out.
I got left back.
Plus he told me you got left back in sixth grade.
Wow.
That's how good that pussy was.
Surely I went to summer school and then tap down on some school.
You can only miss three times.
I couldn't take it.
I get up in morning.
My head would be ready to fucking explode.
I'd watch her mother.
I would struck the mother really soon as I see the mother's cargo around fucking
Charles Court.
It would run in there like fucking Batman after a fucking,
my first girlfriend,
the problem was my first girlfriend was hot.
She was hot and she was a freak and there's some girls who are like 14 and 15
and they look like women and this girl looked,
she looked like women.
She dressed in a little mini skirts and high heels and shit and she was at dirty
bench.
She was came from a single family household and those girls,
like a single parent,
like if you live with just your mom,
like girls who just live with their mom,
like a lot of them it seems they,
they grow up with some sort of an extra need for male attention.
Oh,
extra need for male acceptance and validation.
Nobody home at three o'clock.
This girl just go five.
I tore that ass up.
She just wanted to suck cock and fuck all the time.
She was a freak.
She wants me out.
What's wrong?
Would you listen to shop?
Like to suck my Dick and movie theaters?
Like anything.
What you salt the fuck that and mostly it was like,
oh here,
here,
here I go again.
Put It on again.
I,
it's actually the DEF Leppard days.
I think I was into Leppard crashing,
maybe pour some sugar on me or something.
But this girlfriend was a cool girl.
You know,
she was the first girl,
her name is Bethany.
She was the first girl that I ever,
I'm like,
listen to what Richard Pryor tapes with.
We would sit and sit in my bedroom and Kegel,
listen to these tapes.
It was crazy,
man.
It was like I,
that was the first person that was like not a dude that was like my friend,
you know?
And we just bang all the time.
Like constantly.
It was like this person that you like,
that's not a,
not a,
not a guy and it's a girl.
And I'm also no girls in your life all the time.
Like your whole life.
There's been no girls in your life.
Like I had no girlfriends.
I might've had like one or two along the way.
Cause like girls that were nice that I went to school with,
that I would,
you know,
talk to or hang out with afterschool.
Yeah.
But you know,
for the most part it's a bunch of dudes in my life.
Then all the sudden there's just some girl and you're just fucking so you go
from no sex at all to all of a sudden just fucking constantly do whenever you
want.
Fucking savagery,
man.
Those hormones,
When you,
when you're,
uh,
when people don't understand the concept of 16 year old Dick that you are on a
drug man,
that's a heavy,
super powerful,
super addictive drug.
That's physically when you're supposed to breed.
Yeah.
You should be making a baby right then for sure.
I was trying to make a baby got so lucky.
So lucky.
Woo.
You get super fucking horny.
Oh my God.
That's obsessive.
Mind you don't say a red band.
Red Band sitting over there silent over there in the corner.
Like fucking precious reminiscing.
He's his father's fathers and shot about 150 loads this week.
He's feeling kind of tired.
I'm on duty.
He's back.
Ryan's back between masturbation and all the sexy you've been having,
you freak know he looked bad.
So what six guys?
Come on.
What are you saying?
Why you sound like the Apollo 11 astronauts and it's called flight press
conference the last two days in bed.
Yeah.
Two 48 hours.
Shoot.
Shoot loads.
Yeah.
You've been in bed.
What was the Nivea attached to the bed?
Keep you rehydrated from all the fucking milky white knowledge.
You shoot.
It was a drink too much Friday,
like so much that I couldn't get out of Bedford today.
There Sunday or Monday.
Friday and Saturday.
Really?
Yeah.
Where'd you go
to hell to hell.
That's what I like.
Narnia.
And actually my friend's a manager at Bevmo.
Nice King.
Nobody gets drunk like you,
Huh?
Nobody gets drunk like you.
Uh,
you're dead wrong.
Who else gets,
I think when people get drunk just like me,
but when they're 36,
right?
When you're 18 or definitely drinking more than me.
Saddest thing.
I was in Vegas and I was sober and I ran into this chick that I know used to be
a ring card girl and she was super,
super drunk.
Yeah.
Sloppy her sober and someone else is not.
And you're like,
hey,
how are you doing?
How are you?
And they're just like,
oh yeah.
By the way,
if you see people outside of a pink Floyd concert that you know,
please don't assume that they're just fine.
You know?
Don't just say,
Hey,
I haven't seen you in awhile.
Just fucking say hi and walk away.
Fuck Golan.
Yeah,
no,
please.
What happened?
People say hi,
but it's like,
I don't,
I can't talk to you right now.
That's supposed to be cool that you ran into somebody you know you want to give
you fucking hear beat.
Yeah.
It's a very embarrassing thing when you're intoxicated and the other person
isn't.
Yeah.
You feel like it's also such a loser with our,
I'm drunk or whether I'm stoned.
I always feel like a real idiot if I'm drunk or coked up.
I feel like an idiot.
If I'm stolen,
I feel bad for the other person.
If it's two in the afternoon and you ain't high,
go fuck yourself.
Got On my face.
I want you around me like I want cancer,
my ball sack.
You know what I'm saying?
You got to come around here looking at me with your fucking wide eyes.
Pick him that you know I'm gonna.
I'm gonna Reform.
Go Fuck Yourself.
My morning starts at 5:30 AM either you're there or your square.
You know what I'm saying?
It's true.
That's my new signature on the rogue and board.
If it's still in the afternoon,
Uaa high,
go fuck you.
Fuck yourself.
Shame on you.
You're slipping,
you're slipping.
You're skipping.
If you have a fucking date,
unless,
no,
no.
I want to give a shout out to the American people out there that work back to
get piss test.
You people got food.
I'm Brian about that or my understanding that you guys,
I really do respect you guys.
I see people,
they come to me [inaudible] like great to see you and they like talked to me
about weeds.
I asked him if you want to smoke and they look at me with this pain in their
soul can't,
but I understand your pain so you guys don't listen to this shit.
I love it.
On my oculus fuck.
Republicans and Democrats that walk around all day,
I don't get high till after work.
Go Fuck yourself lunchtime.
I don't mind.
You want to go on at nine and feel the fucking atmosphere and see what's going
on.
You don't want to run into their high into an emergency.
You know what I'm saying it to afford 11 if I want to at 12 o'clock when you
slip off for lunch,
you've got to come with the kit.
Vaizey lifesavers along.
Come with fuck it.
Yeah.
A one hit up that orange spray,
that orange brand you do to into the pipes.
Don't give a fuck what you see right here.
Yep.
We'd kill and spray.
Tell you what is it called?
Orange what aren't chronic chronic sprain.
Ai got too high one time and I got the part where you're like panic attacks and
I was dating Katie at the time and I'm like Katie,
I think uh,
I need you guys to call the ambulance.
I'm too stoned on my heart's pounding too hard.
She goes,
you're fine,
you're fine.
You're just stoned.
I'm like,
no,
please call the ambulance.
And so they were coming over and I had a big bottle of that in my house.
Smelled like weed.
So I sprayed the whole bottle cause I was so scared to call the ambulance to the
house too.
Yeah.
How many times.
And so it's a payment plan with the hospital three times.
Have you called the ambulance brown to that I know of if it's a story because
cause I don't want him to be Guam,
Guam.
So I said,
so I spray a whole bottle because I'm so stoned and paranoid.
I didn't want to get in trouble.
And so they come in here and they were like,
you're fine.
You know your heart's a little little racing,
whatever.
You're fine.
You're probably fucked up from all this orange spray because it was so strong
that they had to put masks on
and I was too stoned to realize if you've called hospitals twice,
you've called an ambulance because you were too high.
There's,
I mean,
there's a big thing,
like when I was a kid,
I had to take stress tests.
I had this thing where I would run around and blackout for no reason and doctors
have no idea why.
So I used to have to do,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Explain that.
What happened?
So like,
all right.
You used to happen like maybe four times.
When I was a kid,
one time when I was running through the snow,
I black out,
I wake up and I'm out laying on the ground.
Second time I'm riding my bike,
I fall off my bike for no reason.
I blacked out and there's been,
there was like a couple of different times like that.
So they used to make me to just blacked out while you were riding a bike?
Yeah.
So they didn't know why.
So they made me do the stress test where they put these things all over your
body and he had to run this treadmill for like an hour or something like that.
And Yeah.
And they said,
hey,
we'd have no idea what's wrong with you.
You know,
then I black out again and all this stuff.
But then it just stopped happening.
And the only time it happens now is like when you jerk off.
No,
no.
When you're,
you know,
when you're drunk and you wake up real quick to go to the bathroom and you start
going,
okay,
I stood up too quick.
And,
um,
yeah,
I get that all the time.
The blood pressure from the blood pressure,
it's just being hammered.
Well,
it only,
it happens more when you're drunk cause of your blood pressure.
Yeah.
So anyways,
um,
I think when I was a kid that I used to always happen all the time and so then I
was extra paranoid with my heart,
like just freaks out all the time.
Like they said that my heart,
uh,
extra night used to tell me yeah,
after that Boone heart,
but I told the ladies,
I have a bad Boone heart sweat to other girls.
You should do a lot of cardio then.
Huh?
I shouldn't,
you look have a healthy strong or the exact opposite.
Yeah.
How's that worked for?
I don't want to use my heart at all,
you know?
Is that the case though?
What do they tell you?
Well,
they have no idea.
Whatever.
They never found out what happened.
Whoa.
Yeah.
But now it doesn't happen.
It's not like I'm blacking out anywhere,
you know,
so.
Right.
But that's why I think in the past,
you know,
and get really big.
My heart starts going crazy.
A little bit different than maybe,
Huh?
Okay.
So it's so freaky that you think that you might be having a heart attack.
Right.
Because when I was a kid,
ever since I was like eight,
I've had fucked up shit.
Yeah,
this boy,
you should know that it's hot.
The story,
I really want to give you a hug.
I feel like you're a little kid that needs a hug.
It's,
you grew up in the psychological now it's like a,
it's like his,
his mind playing tricks on,
I seen somebody pass out from weed.
We were,
uh,
we were in New York,
we're filming fear factor and there was a bunch of people from the crew were all
hanging out and there was this nice lady from production and she,
you know,
we all had a beer or two and we're all out there in the street.
So I go,
you guys want to get high?
And they look at me like,
what do you guys,
what do you got?
Like,
oh,
I got a joint.
I go,
I've got some real shit.
You want to get high?
And you're like,
okay,
let's do it.
I felt like I was being crazy,
like,
can't believe we're doing this.
You know,
they just weren't the type of people to get high.
We're going to smoke all this street on my,
if they do,
they don't get high a lot.
You know,
they might do it every now and then at a party or so.
And so I uh,
I passed this joint around and they take like two hits each,
you know,
which you don't realize if you,
if you get locked up for that medical California medical grade weed is,
that's like an alien organism that takes over your entire body and transports
you to a nearby immersion.
It was like half a hit was so much.
Do you remember
macguire macguire freaked out at the comedy store and was absolutely convinced
someone dose the,
we'd give it to that.
He was like,
those guys like Pete,
you're like,
oh,
he must have done something to that weed.
I smoked it too.
He ended up with some other guy,
that guy that was from Texas and I smoked that joint too.
So I,
I,
you know,
we had to tell McGuire,
no,
it's just really good weed.
There's no way,
because wheat is less strong,
newly just don't wait.
So it's not,
I'm telling you man,
I think there's a problem.
I think it's a real agenda.
Genuine problem.
I was like really freaked out cause he doesn't get high.
And Chris is,
you know,
he's a small guy so it must've,
he was smoking with Joey in May in [inaudible].
We're hitting that weed,
you know,
and Wu two or three hits of your,
if you're a real rookie.
So this check we're all out.
We're all passing joints around.
They're all freely till you want another one.
You sure?
All right.
Get in there,
look at you second.
Hit her eyes,
roll back in her head and she just collapses right there on the fucking sidewalk
man.
And almost cracked her head off a pole.
We had a catcher.
We were right there like ruck luckily was her legs gave out.
I thought she was kidding.
I thought she was like,
Whoa,
this is weird.
It's those drug a little before.
But no,
her eyes rolled behind her head.
She went unconscious like what is it about your body that wants you to shut off?
Like what kind of a lack of self preservation does your body have?
I think about that shit.
You get hit,
you get hurt,
you,
your body wants to shut off.
You take a,
you smell smoke some weed,
you get too high and your body wants to shut.
Your body's just not used to.
It's like if you went back at a time you saw yourself like you know when Michael
J.
Fox went back and saw himself and they both fainted and freaked out.
You know your mind just shuts off cause it's too much shock.
It's like Bam,
you're,
you know,
you just first time you take care of your bar.
Why don't buy that?
Because you're,
you're selling saying that you never blacked out when you were on acid and acid
sounds way crazier than that.
If anything should make you black out into that blow the smoke.
I think you're too awake with the acid.
You can't sleep for 12 hours on acid.
The last thing you want to do is sleep.
Why?
But that's what I'm saying.
I mean,
but it's an insane experience.
Right?
It's like so overwhelming.
No,
because I mean,
every time I black out,
it was out of the blue.
I was just riding my bike.
Bam.
I was,
those were running in the,
you know,
Snow.
Well,
that's the,
that you had a weird condition.
When I'm talking to most like smoking weed or drinking or something like that,
like,
or even getting hit,
like what a weird thing it is that if you get hit and hurt,
your body wants to just shut off the puzzle going to help you.
Exactly.
It's gonna make you feel less pain as animals eating,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
As his animals,
there's always set the duff.
Really?
Yeah.
There's kind of,
you see them like they run,
they run the kick and then it's like they just lie there.
You know?
That's how native Americans used to catch deer before they invented spears and
even bows and arrows.
They would run after them until the deer would give up and die.
Wow.
Yeah.
They,
they still do it in some parts of Africa.
It's like some sort of a bitches.
Joe [inaudible] my dog.
That's why they're all wearing high heels and skirts,
maneuverable.
But that kind of outfit on how they,
uh,
they do it.
Some
parts of Africa,
it's like a rite of passage,
you know,
you go after a,
an antelope and fucking run that bitch down until the thing dies or fatigue.
Then they stab it.
Wow.
Yeah.
They run with a knife,
carry it back,
and then when the thing gives up and they just go over it and fucking stab in
the heart and that's a wrap.
It just gives up.
Doesn't,
can't run anymore.
Do you think in Africa that,
is it Africa that has so much,
so much,
uh,
aids,
right?
Like most people have like 75%.
Like they have the most Kentucky Fried.
Yeah.
But it's like 75% aids there or something like that.
Right.
Not Crazy big.
Well,
I don't know what it is,
what they've got.
There's a lot of A's.
So if you didn't have aids,
you would have the aids.
Right.
Except that no one got 5% of the people at AIDS.
That's like the norm.
So if you don't have aids,
you have the aid.
So people are looking out the window and look at him.
He looks like he wears protection,
you know,
like whether it be backwards on the road.
And you know,
well there's a lot of debate when it comes to AIDS in Africa and the let the
debate,
a lot of it is on what is,
how do you define aids?
Do you define aids by someone who has erect immune system and what does that
immune system wrecked from?
Can't you just look at the music library actually wrecked from HIV?
Is it rec from other disease or is it racked from massive malnutrition?
You know,
these people are like really like and terrible environments as far as like
water,
like clean water and,
and,
and food and you know,
nutrition.
And there's a lot of people that are dying of all sorts of crazy shit.
And I think a lot of it gets lumped in as aids.
You know,
there's,
I think there's a lot of issues.
So it's not just HIV and HIV is certainly an issue in Africa.
I mean there's a,
it's an insane amount of people have it and on top of that,
one of the ways they try to cure it is they try to kill Albinos and they do
witchcraft and shit with Albinos.
Virgin and fuck virgins versions have aids.
They believe that.
Yeah,
you can get rid of the rape,
a 12 year old version.
I mean we talk about Africa so often because if you want to get online and start
tweaking and weird and out about the state of the world,
go look at Africa.
Africa is I,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not going to Africa now.
Ne got No desire.
We talked about going to Africa.
I don't think so.
Probably.
Let's talk about,
I was going to Brazil,
man.
Prostitute,
just talking.
Boy,
we're definitely going back to sa to Australia.
We're going all over the fucking place.
Cool.
There was a real bad decision at the last year I've seen that a man was talking
about and that's bullshit.
That is one of the,
that's just ridiculous.
I like how you did your speech though.
That was fucking awesome.
Perfect.
It's exactly what I think most people were thinking.
I said that we have to get rid of some of these judges that you can set up
during the what?
Threw in another fight.
Oh,
during the middle of the fight.
I was talking about the last fight and I was,
it was such a bad decision.
I've never had like that many people screaming bullshit.
Like the whole crowd was screaming bullshit.
They were all pissed.
You know?
There was very few people cheering.
It was like obviously Nam Pan one Vitor was like,
I know I lost.
He had just lost now though.
Oh,
he doesn't know.
He thinks he wants more damage or,
yeah.
What,
what's the,
what's the count?
There's websites that deal all the camps and we beat them by a considerable
margin on the counts of like connecting and also,
you know,
it's not just that,
it's like the second round was so overwhelming for that dude.
There's a bunch of issues and one of the issues is the actual scoring system
that they have in place is taken from boxing and it's not a good scoring system.
The 10 point must system because like there's a guy named doc Hamilton and he's
a referee who has a,
a,
a real or is a judge rather.
And he was a referee as well and he has a good idea and it's a half point
system.
And what that system would be like,
say like the first round of Nan fan and uh,
and um,
Leonard Garcia,
you would say nam fan one,
but how closely did he win it?
And it'd be half a point.
Give him a half point.
But the second round he took them down,
he beat him up.
Like the second round was pretty clear.
So you'd give them a full point for that round and then the third round,
who won that round?
Well,
you know,
I could see a debate either way and that would be a half point round as well.
That could threaten people like barely losing two round.
Yeah,
crushing another round.
Exactly.
Machida rampage was a perfect example.
You know a lot of people gave rampage the first two rounds because he pushed the
fight.
But the third round was clearly Machida because he did a bunch of damage.
Then they took rampage down.
So rampage would maybe get a half a point for each of the first and then there
would be a third round and he would get up.
But she didn't get a full point for that round.
And then what would happen is if it was a draw,
which it would be in that case,
they would rely on a fourth judge who only calculates damage.
So the fourth judge through the whole fight,
like say if you take him down,
you get them in side control,
that's x amount of points.
And if you hit him with a leg kick that makes them wins,
Any tallies,
all these up while the fights going on.
So this guy doesn't have to decide who wins each round.
All this fourth guide is doing,
it's like,
yeah,
who's doing [inaudible]?
Judge almost got a rear naked choke or almost got,
where's the,
what you call them?
They would do what's called a catch.
And they used to do this and in Japan when a guy was really close to landing a
submission,
like say if he uh,
he got the back,
got the hooks in,
he's over the chin,
but he's,
he's trying to choke the guy and it's not quite in yet.
It's called catch.
And what catches like it's really close.
It's really close.
It's like this is a near submission and that counts as points.
Why don't they make the judges have to be x fighters or at least have black
belts and they're not allowed to play angry birds.
I mean,
let them do something that's absolutely 100% what I've been saying,
what I've been saying for a long time is that there's a lot of fans as well and
people that train as well that would love to do it.
But the problem is is that the waste state athletic commissions are like,
they're just like working for the government and it's really hard to get fired.
Super hard to get fired.
And,
um,
they,
everybody wants to think that there's no problem and everybody wants to say,
oh,
we're doing our best.
And everybody,
you know,
doesn't agree on fights and these are good judges and no they're not.
They don't,
there's a lot of shit they don't know.
A lot of them come over from boxing.
They literally have no experience and no training in this sport other than
people explaining to them what these moves are and then they have to judge them.
But it's the highest levels of the game.
It's so hard to know where you stand.
If judge can be two rounds off,
it's terrible.
I mean,
someone could be like,
I won those two rounds.
Someone else,
like I won those two rounds.
Yeah.
And there's some of them,
there's some of them that really,
really suck.
There's some of them that really have no idea what they're doing.
Then I've,
I have friends who are judges who have told me in frustration that,
you know,
certain women judges have actually turned to them in the middle of fights while
guy was obviously attempting a certain position,
like a Kamora or something like that and said,
what is this?
What is he doing?
Like she literally,
it's like your girlfriend judging a fight.
You know what I'm saying?
Like she doesn't know what's happening.
He's got cute hair.
He totally wins.
And what my,
my point audit and the reason why I said it is because one of my biggest issues
is that the guy who's the president of the staff,
the Nevada state athletic commission,
the guys were running everything.
He's not willing to admit that he has not done the best job possible with the
best intentions of the sport and its participants.
He has not done the best job possible he's at,
he's trying to pretend that the people that he has in place are fine and that
everything's good and it's not good.
Who says boss bad decision after bad decision after bad decision with no change.
Because in order to make a change,
he has to admit that there's a problem.
And if he admits it is a problem,
then he admits he's wrong.
And that's something that politicians never want to do.
So he tries to pretend that everything's fine,
so he keeps point in the same people with the same problems and we want same guy
forever.
Yeah,
the State Athletic Commission Guy has been the same from Keith Pfizer.
And who's his boss?
Anybody?
I don't know.
I don't know who it is,
but you know,
people are emailing man,
people going crazy after this one.
We need to find out who his boss is,
get his Twitter.
The online community is taken care of.
Everything down.
The online community is beyond pissed that all this,
these people are huge fans and these people appreciate what all these fighters
have to go through that there's a massive fucking commitment involved and trying
to be a professional MMA fighter.
And the last thing they should have to deal with at this level of the game is a
bunch of people judging the fights that don't know what's going on.
It's one thing if it's a subjective opinion and the,
you know,
there's one guy that says,
I think that leg kicks don't count as much as head punches cause head punches,
you know,
can knock you out.
Leg Kicks,
it takes a bunch of them.
There's a lot of subjective,
you know,
arguments about what's more,
what's,
you know,
what's worth more take down or you know,
a good jab.
You know,
what is worth more.
If God takes you down and he doesn't really do anything when he gets you down,
but you hit him with a stiff jab and his nose is bleeding.
Isn't the stiff jab worth more?
What is worth more?
It's a,
it's an interesting debate,
but this isn't a debate man.
This is like,
people don't know shit.
They just don't know.
And it's crazy to watch and it's crazy to watch this guy who's at the head of
the state athletic commission pretend that it's not a problem.
It's fine.
It's Nevada is,
look,
it's not just a lot of,
there's issues with other states in the other states will grow with mixed
martial arts is of new sport and a lot of these states they're starting to put
their athletic commissions together and they're trying to piece it together and
they're trying to do the right thing.
Boston is doing a real good job and one of the guys in the commission is
actually my f my former karate teacher,
Scott Joe Esposito.
So there's a lot of martial artists.
That's what you want.
You want people that are real,
real fans of the sport.
I don't believe this guy's a fan of the sport.
I believe this guy is a politician and I don't believe it.
That's good for,
for what we need.
I think what's going on is that we have a bunch of people that were
grandfathered in from boxing.
So there are all these people that worked for the State Athletic Commission.
They're judging boxing fights and now they say,
well okay this is boxing.
But there's a bunch of other stuff going on too.
Like take downs and that's like you see someone coming up to me and saying,
hey dude,
you are a,
you are a commentator on mixed martial arts,
right?
We want you to start commentating on football.
Right?
And you'd be like,
well,
I don't know anything about football.
Well,
they hit each other,
they slam into each other and it's violent.
Nothing you do do that thing you do.
Exactly.
And I'd be like,
what do I have to do?
I have to judge football shit.
Uh,
did he do the right thing?
And you know,
you don't,
you don't fucking,
you don't understand the sport,
man.
You've got to understand the sport to be judging it.
You have to participate in it.
You have to have trained,
you have to have some experience.
You have to know the line.
It just makes sense.
There's some classes going,
got another housewives.
But if they don't know this is the training,
take them to a gym and show in the movie.
Exactly.
It's not just showing the moves,
man,
I think you need to train.
And I don't think we,
I think there's plenty of fucking people out there.
They have,
there's x fighters,
there's,
there's people that are just big fans of the sport that understand all the
aspects of it,
the ground game,
the standup game and you have to have that and you,
most importantly,
you have to have a very deep and sincere appreciation of what these guys go
through and how much they're putting out there,
what they're laying on the line.
And in my opinion,
when you keep using week officials and you keep having problems with,
with judging,
you're not respecting what these guys are doing.
There's a sport a little bit does hurt the sport.
Kind of a bad booze was like,
wait,
yes,
that seems cheap.
Exactly.
Seed rigged and that's why I had to say it man.
And they're like,
well why'd you have to say that?
That's not professional.
It's absolutely professional.
You have to say it.
If I don't say it,
it's not professional.
I don't if who's going to say it,
if I don't know buddy,
we just going to stick our head in the sand and pretend is not an issue.
These people that are watching this at home,
they'll start screaming.
The UFC is fixed.
It's like fucking wrestling.
It's like boxing.
It's bullshits.
Fear can get into if you don't know who's ahead.
Exactly.
So I had to let,
I had to let people know that it's not fixed.
It's incompetence and they want to continue the way it's the way it's always
been and they don't want me talking about it.
It's hilarious.
The whole thing's hilarious.
Picking up hilarious.
Speaking of Hillary,
I have a show tonight.
Yes.
The Melrose Improv.
Fascinating and hilarious.
It's a storyteller show and Joe Diaz is performing as well.
That's right.
What are you talking about Joey?
It's a story when ours does these really interesting shows at the Improv lab and
what it is is that there's a,
the Improv on Melrose and there's another room right next to it that's the lab
and it's all like X.
I've done it a couple times.
It's all like experimental shit.
Like dudes just go up and tell stories about things.
Some guys try to do standup,
some guys do,
but some guys just live,
live and up there at the pump,
the fuck story ones huff because everyone has fucked stories as bits.
You know,
there was a few guys I walked in on,
I'm like,
this guy's like a violating this,
the principal,
this guy's doing his act like with all the pauses in the right places and like,
but you know,
some people just went up and tell stories or Tommy Chong told the story about
how he got arrested and held it got complacent and stuff about drugs and,
and you know,
in airports and stuff,
which is really interesting.
It's on the lineup.
The lineup is Bill Burr,
Joey Diaz.
Um,
Kathleen Madigan.
Nice.
Bobby Lee.
Um,
and Steve Agee soon,
something like that.
Go wrong with that.
That's five bucks and it's $5.
It's only $5.
It's tonight at eight o'clock.
And how do they get tickets?
You can go to the improv.com and look for the Hollywood and if you want to go,
don't get tickets
now cause we're talking about this shit.
A lot of people are listening.
A lot of people are gonna hear about it on Twitter.
It's gonna sell out tonight because it's only like,
what is it?
Like a hundred seats at Roswell?
It's going to be the main room.
Oh you're doing in the main room?
Yeah,
they moved it over.
Shit.
That's how big it is.
Bitches.
This shit's getting lodge.
Could go in there and there's a code to get cheaper.
Um,
service charges.
This is not happening.
Presents,
that's the name I n.
H.
P.
Yeah.
How much cheaper or the drinks if they say that and other drinks,
that service charge.
If you buy the tickets online,
there's an extra $3 or $5 ticket.
And I told you three extra per ticket and I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
And they were like,
all right,
well we'll offer you this.
Some sort of keep getting what w why would it cost them $3?
It's process.
A credit left,
settled,
anything under like 20 bucks cost that much.
It's it's modem fee for service fees when you're using a computer.
No one's doing it.
Exactly.
I print out my own ticket.
What service supposed to be the whole thing.
I mean you are paying taxes on it,
aren't you?
Don't you pay taxes on tickets?
Yeah.
It's part of the why.
I don't have to be a service fee.
Well into the ticket ropes.
Cops that an that was I,
there's people are greedy man.
People.
People just want too much money for shit.
Yeah.
T you know,
you're not supposed to get rich selling tickets as whole,
you know you ain't [inaudible].
All you're doing is like providing people with a little piece of paper that gets
them into the show.
The show is where it's at,
so you shouldn't be getting almost as much as the show.
The show's getting five bucks.
You get three.
Fuck you douchebags yeah.
That's when it doesn't work out.
It's ridiculous.
Is that code?
It's only a dollar.
So this is not happening.
Is that happening and HP p the shows the year in or we're just doing all the
topics we've done so far.
What are you talking about tonight is I got a few ideas,
having a few ideas.
I haven't really,
I haven't really gone deep with them.
Give them yet.
You know what I'm saying?
You've got so many God damn stories never met a human being that has more stores
than you today.
You told new ones.
I didn't think you had any new ones.
I've known you for over a decade and every fucking die we've talked to as a new
one comes out,
man bro.
He remembers.
I don't know how you do it.
I don't know how you view your life.
Must've been insane.
Your life growing up as a kid must've been just fucking completely insane.
The amount of stories that you have.
I love it.
Talk Good.
Cock sucker.
Hey,
have you guys been paying attention to this wikileaks shit?
Yeah,
they arrested the guy for having sex without a condom.
Is that what it was like?
I should so fake that he's going to be dead in like three days.
They arrested him on a charge and sweating bullets.
It's somehow similar to rape to not,
it's something that it's like charging somebody sodomy here if you have sex
without a condom.
Unconsensually no,
it was consensual.
Yeah.
Twice.
Two girls [inaudible] restaurants trying to kill this guy or give him some drug
or touch his penis,
but I didn't know that that's what the charge was.
I thought it was like sexual assault or something like that.
They trumped up.
Really?
Yeah.
Are you sure?
No,
I'm not sure.
I don't even know if the guy real name,
I don't know what anything is.
Get your magic if it's not even
real.
He's just like an actor that they using to get all this information out.
The whole thing.
It's very strange,
man,
to releasing all these secrets about China.
They're all,
all these Chinese studies that they're doing,
man,
and one of them was quantum teleportation.
Whoa,
cool.
Quantum communication.
I guess it's not as like space 1999 is we're wrap our heads around.
It's not like star Trek.
We were teleporting things from one place to another.
They're working on some,
some way of distributing information where it only exists in one place,
then you can transport it to another place.
It's like it totally,
uh,
undecided.
Uncrackable the idea is that you could have like,
you know,
you could send information,
not have to worry about anybody picking it up along the way.
You know,
this whole thing happened because there was an employee that brought in a lady
Gaga CD and it looked like he was just fucking playing music on his computer and
this motherfucker was just downloading shit onto this,
this CDR with lady Gaga written on it.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's what happened man.
The whole thing is very fascinating.
91,000 classified U s military documents were dumped last week.
Just saying fuck it.
Everybody know this guy just,
I don't know,
I don't know how it all got started.
I'm,
but I'm,
I'm fascinated to have heard a story on NPR about it and they said they have
pled pleaded with him.
Sometimes we're like about certain things like don't release this.
And he's listened to them a couple times where it's like,
okay,
you've made a point,
this will hurt people.
I'm going to not release that.
Has He done that?
Won't release a few things where it fits.
It'll just lead to someone's harm and no one needs that information.
Man.
The whole thing is such a trip,
you know,
it's,
we're finding out how they communicate and how they,
uh,
talk about,
different parts of the world and all the different problems that people have.
Yeah.
Here's one of them.
A Texas company,
they're saying help pimp little boys to a Afghany cops.
This is really crazy.
That's to be released to hurt besides the people who are doing stuff.
Yeah.
The company's called Din core private security contractor tasked with training
the Afghan police,
the companies officially based in DC area.
Most of his businesses managed on a satellite campus at alliance airport,
north of Fort Worth.
And one of the diplomatic cables from the wikileaks archives is to be believed.
These guys apparently are,
this is somebody,
this guy named Hans von posted this on the Rogan board.
This,
um,
the apparently were bringing in boys,
this is fucking crazy man.
And yet you gotta think,
man,
look,
there's,
if you know anything about Afghanistan that is the tradition there.
It's been going on for a long,
long time.
They have sex with boys.
It's like guys who have gone over there,
I've talked to military guys will do,
especially when we do these,
um,
fight for the troops.
You can get a long time to talk to these dudes.
And this guy was telling me about catching guys fucking like you would just in
Afghanistan,
they would just catch guys fucking like,
that'd be a on on patrol or they'd be doing something and they'd be,
you know,
soldiers will be fucking,
no,
no.
Two Afghanis.
They're just banging each other.
Like they're just pull over somewhere and then just,
you know,
they're behind a fucking fence,
fucking each other,
sucking each other's cocks or something.
He's like,
it's like they have sex with boys all the time
over there.
It's apparently just,
you know,
you hear about it like from the Greek empire and the Roman Empire will
apparently,
it's still going on in certain parts of things like,
okay,
you might make a call where it's like that's acceptable in their society,
so we're going to allow it,
but you shouldn't hide it.
Yeah.
Little Boys,
man,
like young boys.
It's like super common.
Apparently they spoke a lot of pot to the Afghani soldiers,
so this company,
then we ship it to the kids at where they shipping them out of Texas to have
Gail feel American boys.
I know.
That's a good question.
I didn't read the whole story.
No Way.
Yeah,
that'd be,
that'd be nuts.
No,
to be Afghani boys,
I would assume.
Right.
Did they charge a service fee of you order online for those who can't get the
clothes for free by Baka.
Bazi is a pre Islamic Afghan tradition that was banned by the Taliban and Baka
Boyz r eight to 15 years old.
They put on makeup,
they tied bells to their feet and they slip,
slip into scanty women's clothing.
And then to the wine of harmonium and wailing vocals,
they dance.
Abductive doctor [inaudible] to smokey roomfuls of leering older men.
This is what this Guy Hans von wrote.
That's fucking crazy,
man.
Wow.
There's no shame in having a little boy lover on the contrary.
It's a matter of pride.
Those who can afford the most attractive boy,
our players,
the ogs of places like Kandahar and coast.
How old's the boy?
It's a frontline vape eight to 15,
eight to 15.
And I could sort of see,
you know what dude,
we,
we've talked about this before,
but you people get used to everything.
You know,
people get used to whatever the culture is around you.
You get used to the crazy traditions that people have as far as like,
you know,
when I was in,
um,
uh,
Germany,
they had a television channel that was,
uh,
it was the,
the Hodge on,
uh,
Mecca,
if that's how you say it,
the Hodge [inaudible].
Anyway,
it's on TV at 25 Mecca Cam.
Oh.
And there's a,
if you've ever seen Mecca,
there's like a building.
It's like this a flat box that's in the center and all these people are milling
around this.
And I'm looking at this and I'm like,
you could if you started this up tomorrow.
And he said,
hey,
you know,
this is what we're doing.
We're going to all meet in this one super secret,
cool spot.
And we're going to start walking around in a circle where people would start
going,
well,
what's in that box?
Why am I walking around this?
This is stupid.
Why do I have to wear this white robe?
What's in the box?
Exactly?
What is it?
I Dunno.
I have no idea.
But the point is that it's been done for so long that doing,
it's normal.
It's just normal.
It's just the thing we did.
So if it's,
if it's banging kids or if it's a everybody banks,
kids,
okay,
I'll get a kid to bang.
You know,
what does it,
you know that those African women that like fucking stuff plates in their lips
or those Thai people that like stick fucking swords through their faces.
Why do they do that?
Because they're all doing it.
Everybody's done it.
So you do it too.
You know,
there's a lot of follow the leader going on with people,
man.
And somehow or another,
if,
if they all decide that banging kids is okay,
then it's okay then it's okay.
Yeah.
Dog findings.
Okay.
And a lot of cultures,
a lot of cultures.
And how can you blame somebody?
All the Indians would come over here like,
wait,
you're not allowed to have sex with a 17 year old?
I don't understand.
Yeah,
I don't know about that.
You know,
my um,
my gardener,
my ex gardener actually,
um,
used to fight chickens and he took them,
that's illegal too.
He used to fight chickens.
So,
uh,
he took me to why he does not the guy that works for me now.
So,
um,
he used to fight chickens and he took me to,
uh,
you know,
like chicken buddy's house.
Yeah.
They had,
this guy has a whole backyard set up.
It's in the most Mexican neighborhood of La.
You've ever been to ever?
I don't want to say where it is,
but you get there and all the signs are in Spanish,
Bro.
Everything's in Spanish.
Everyone's Mexican for blocks and blocks and blocks and every one's got
chickens.
The whole backyard.
[inaudible]
everywhere you go is by pit bulls and chickens.
These motherfuckers had pit bulls and chickens and mind my gardener,
I gave him one of my pit bull puppies.
So he had one of Frank's puppies turned out to be a crazy dog.
That's a long story.
And uh,
he's got like fucking 20 chickens in his backyard.
Wow.
This guys would go and they would get hammered and they would,
uh,
they would roast a goat.
That's what they do that kill a goat.
And they would,
uh,
put a fire on the ground,
put the goat on a spit role,
the goat around a barbecue,
and then they'd start chicken fights and they would get fucking hammered and
they'd all get together in this guy had a giant yard.
It was all set up with chicken like breeding.
That sounds fun to me.
It does sound fun.
Barbecued booze and just what people like,
what are you doing?
It's cruelty to animals and forcing these animals to fight each other,
I guess.
But you know how come it's okay to eat them,
but it's not okay to watch them beat the fuck out of each other?
Yeah.
Isn't that what they want to do?
The kill him?
I guess the problem is also they give razor blades.
They put razor blades on their spurs.
Oh yeah,
they don't,
I mean,
they don't cut each other up because of their beaks.
That shit forever.
Wow.
Yeah.
They totally fix it.
The way they fight.
It's kind of harmless.
I mean,
they can,
they can occur,
hurt each other eventually,
but take it going to take some time.
So they put razor blades on their sperm.
They put spurs on their paws clawing.
Another one,
you just chop it up.
Obviously.
I don't think you should have chicken fights,
but for them it's a huge part of their culture and it's a lot of fucking fun and
they love it.
And the gamble on it.
They'll get together and you know,
he would tell me about the different strains of rooster about his friend has
this new strain.
It's like championship fighting strain and he brought it in and the,
he brought this,
the rooster and they showed me the rooster like take into the cage.
He's a bad motherfucker.
You see this roof too?
So I'll send you Ian Shit.
We'll do you know what fucking evil.
Look in his eyes.
You could tell Lowe's is good genetics.
Wow.
Prime Brewster assassin genetics.
If chicken bites we of growing up.
No,
I see them towards the stock sites got price.
That's what they call man.
Yeah.
Roy Jones Jr apparently he likes to fight chickens.
Really?
Yeah.
If somebody's telling me a story about him when he was in the prime of his
career,
when Roy Jones like Roy Jones,
you know,
it's like dominating everybody.
He was in a private jet and he had to stop over somewhere to pick up some
chickens.
So he stopped over and they're flying in a private jet with Roy Jones and his
boxes of chicken all over the place.
On a fucking private jet.
Roy Jones is chilling with his fucking,
with as Nike's on and Shit.
Wow.
Diamonds and shit with chickens.
He just likes chicken fights,
man who doesn't.
It's a strange thing that you know the want the need to bet on animals chip
fighting to thrill.
Yeah,
it is.
Well,
it's like,
you know the fix is not in,
they're going to go for it.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true too.
But when you see the chickens fight and you see these people that are there,
these people are scary.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
it's not OTB bitch.
No,
this is it.
A little level of deeper than Otb Oh,
Turkey bettering.
You'll take off track betting on the closed TB in New York.
Why close their bridge though?
The one,
did you see what was a thousand them all over?
They try to get legislatures some shit on showing that people gamble.
God dammit.
[inaudible] how many people out there are what?
They should let people gamble online.
They should let people gamble in pool halls,
in bowling alleys.
Gambling is fun and she'd be completely,
totally legal.
And the idea behind it is that,
oh,
people get addicted to gambling.
Dean use people get addicted to anything to get the ice.
I've been addicted to Q tips.
You know,
should q-tips be illegal?
C'Mon man,
this is stupid.
Let him gamble.
God dammit.
I see Otb cause one person to tell you what you can and can't do with your
money.
That's where your money just tax it.
Tax Id.
And if it's a personal thing between two people like plan,
like guys who play basketball,
there should be a little LR to gamble.
It's kind of fun.
I can tell you in a whole DVD,
I don't to pay taxes on that.
It's like why are you probably are [inaudible] claim it?
Wow.
I think you should be able to gamble on whenever the fuck you want.
It's not even,
you shouldn't have,
it's not income man.
You know why?
Because when you work you,
you earn something and that's income professional gamers,
they pay income taxes.
Yeah,
but that's different.
That's a job.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean these guys are entering into professionally run tournaments and shit,
but what I'm saying is if you're betting 20 bucks and against against another
guy who's also betting 20 bucks,
when you win that 20 bucks,
you shouldn't have to pay taxes on it because you risk $20 to make $20 you know
what I'm saying?
Kill.
Yeah.
It's not like charging points are in their entry fee.
Pay 50 grand to get into the world series of poker with all winter.
Exactly.
Lose it all or winner.
It's not like pay 50 bucks to win 5,000,002 dudes putting them both up.
Yeah.
What?
Like what does it cost when you go into the world or series of poker?
It's not cheap,
right?
10 grand,
$10,000 God damn,
you gotta be a player.
You've got to be a player to step up and throw 10 grand at a game that you're
probably not going to win.
I'm probably like 9,590 700 that goes to the prize pool.
My friend Justin from the action report.com.
He's a guy that you met the big giant barely do who uh,
who does the um,
all the live streams for a pool matches and shit.
And he was talking to me about about poker players.
Amount of poker players are starting to gamble on pool now over as poker
players.
Don't give a fuck about $10,000.
$10,000 isn't shit to them,
to a pool player.
It's a big score.
So these poker players,
when they're bored,
there's this one guy named tippy Dave,
he's like the rage of the fucking pool community cause he's going off,
he's like losing 20,000,
30,000 there and he just won 80,000.
He beat this guy,
Alex Pangolin is just top level Filipino player.
A lot of the best players are from the Philippines.
I top level Filipino player.
He beat him for 80,000.
And everybody's going crazy.
This guys like willing to place
it,
but they gave him a crazy spot.
They play a game called one pocket and instead of like having an even number
balls,
they need to get in each other's pocket.
The Filipino guy has to get 18 and he has to get four to make it somewhat even
so ridiculous spot.
It's not real happy very well that game.
Then it's like,
exactly.
So he's winning.
He's winning some of the,
some of the matches go into some of the money,
but you know these poker players,
man there,
they used to gamble in like $1 million on this and a million dollars on that.
And that book that you told me to read,
I bought it about that guy who was the really Felix Unger.
What's his name?
Stuart Stuart Hunger.
Fuck.
Steve Unger.
Unger poker.
All right,
let's find out real quick.
Through hunger,
through the lava lamp,
making tons of money.
Lost it all.
Fucking live in large.
Yeah.
Want a ton of money again lost at all.
Well that's the deal with all these guys are crazy,
crazy like wild gamblers.
Like the,
the best guys.
Apparently one of the,
the,
the attributes they have is they're not afraid to lose.
So they,
that's how they win.
They just throw money at shit and they like,
see what happens.
Alex Pal line,
this guy wins $30,000 playing poker.
Okay.
He's just like kicking everybody's ass playing poker.
He gets his money up.
So he's looking for another game,
another pool match.
Kaz a couple drinks goes to the roulette table,
roulette table beaus it all goes to the dice table,
blows it all.
Just one of those guys,
he'll be at $10,000 in his pocket.
That's just,
I gotta I gotta be an action man.
I gotta be an action.
Wow.
They get crazy and he start going off.
And so this is a weird addiction.
The addiction to gamble.
I growing up around,
uh,
in pool play in a,
at,
uh,
this place,
white plains,
billions.
There was a bunch of people in New York when I,
when I lived there in white plains,
uh,
executive billiards in white plains.
And there was a bunch of people that were like serious hardcore gambling addicts
and never seen anything like it in my life,
man,
they had to be an action in something playing gin,
playing pool,
going to the race track.
It's no fun for him.
There's nothing now.
Life was all about action sport game for about four months and I fucking hate
it.
Really.
I do as a means to survive.
I was a plot man.
You're real good at breaking down fight and I would imagine you would be real
good at breaking down games as well.
You can't do it every day now why does that go to the world?
It's impossible.
The odds are always against your Vegas keeps getting bigger and bigger.
A professional gambler knows when to go in bang and pull out four nights and you
get some mouse has very high percentage.
He looks at the time of the year.
He looks at show many variables who won on Saturday one on Friday,
but it seems to me that,
it seems to me that it'd be super risky no matter what.
Even if you're really good at it.
What are the,
what's the odds that you,
when is it,
55 60 like 78 they always get you,
this is the time of the year right now where they shut the lights on a
motherfucker,
but who do you know you get up to 60% wins.
That's great.
Yeah and that's why when guys go on bad streaks they go bad and it gets scary
because they could want to totally dead,
dead empty.
These guys that take 19 pics,
I love when I make a joy karate view and people like you've got to put the pixel
all them,
you dumb fuck everybody's
going to go for and for what three and five you dummy,
I'm trying to give you info here so you can go to or three specific so you have
it that winter.
So at least you cover on one of the points.
You just not sitting there fucking sweat.
And I'm not sure if the sports book covers all the fights either.
They only cover a couple of them,
but a lot of people like when you bring in guys like Charles Oliveira from
Brazil or something like that,
like who the fuck knows who that guy is and I'll send you killer.
There was a lot of dudes,
man in the early days of the UFC that a,
they used to put the line on when the,
especially when you have fights at the palm and shit,
they would put a lineup and I would look at the line,
I'll go,
I got a bet and these guys don't even know who the fuck this guy is.
Who's a bunch of times where I was stealing money.
You would think some guy was a fan favorite because a lot of people knew about
them so they would put money on whatever the product guys came over on my bet
against them.
Yeah,
because everyone thinks her name is bigger than they are.
Well,
the pride guys,
the situation with pride is first of all,
apparently according to Phil Baroni,
it's much tougher to fly from Japan to America.
That is from America to Japan.
Something to do with like rhythm and cycles of your body and he totally truly
believes this and he says,
this is the reason why these Japanese guys come over here and they don't do so
well.
But another problem with Japan as they were allowed to free ball and take
whatever the fuck they wanted,
these guys were just,
it was a wild west man.
They were just taking all kinds of,
go ahead,
Bob.
Sapp and Bob's had was 375 pounds with ABS.
Have you ever even seen anything like that?
You work with them.
Joey,
you work with them on the longest yard.
What was that like?
And he couldn't pick me up really?
He couldn't fit we,
it was one scene where he was supposed to carry me.
He couldn't pick me up.
Joey,
you,
but how big were you back to read the navy?
He was three 75 and he couldn't pick me up.
Jesus,
he had a fight or wrestle.
I bet fucking against them.
Yeah,
there's restless,
but dude,
very few people can hoist up a 390 pound man.
There's not a whole lot of people.
That's a different kind of weight.
It's a,
it's the way you stay.
I though a lot of people,
if I add a carry you like up out of a burning building,
we're both going to die.
That really I have to drag you if you use your technique,
my Jujitsu techniques.
Shit.
What about my back weighed 390 bro.
You know what?
I can do three 90 for one squat with a bar.
Shit,
Wade perfectly on my shoulders with a spotter,
you know,
making sure there's a bar in place.
Three 90 of human bone and movable tissue and everything switched.
A moving ball sack,
throwing off equilibrium became my head of my boss.
Like that slows you right the fuck the right when I get you on my shoulder,
I step on your Dick and trip.
Oh that the scale off.
Completely wrapping around your legs,
man.
I remember one time you were sitting in a chair and I got behind you and I'll
put you in a gable grip and I just said,
let me see if I got to hoist this dude up.
It was a joke.
It was like trying to pick up a house.
It was like,
I might as well have been trying to pick up my house.
Just didn't budge.
I gripped the whole of them tightened down at just arch my back.
It was like nothing.
It was like my body was like,
dude,
you're going to break everything.
If you try this,
stop what you're doing.
Stupid.
No fucking chance.
No chance to get that water would go get.
I'm over here dying of thirst.
I either hate it.
Banana bread before I came up here.
Fucked up here.
Just sit here and watch.
It happened over the last hour where you slowed down considerably.
Sunk into the hole,
but I back bitch.
You know what I'm saying?
I never go down like that.
I'm like Columbus.
I keep coming back to China.
Woman.
I'm in New York.
Dat,
dat,
dat.
The we're back.
Bitches.
What about flashlight?
Get mythologist boulder in the house.
Fleshlight the only putting up my boy.
Doug's doctors are fucking hollered down in Florida.
Hold that tight with a bicycle.
Him.
Bali,
Tony Wagner,
my buddy Doug,
he knuckles a fucking animal.
I read this thing.
He really run all around the Atlanta bicycle.
Tricycle is back on.
He's got a big fucking head to Doug in not tugging knuckles,
almost bigger than mine.
And that's it guys.
You know what I'm saying?
We're here,
we're queer,
everything's beautiful.
What go to the economist.com my late by latest a cosmology article that I'm
fascinated with,
I haven't quite wrapped my head around this.
I don't want to come comment on and totally,
but the idea is that in the headline is in contradiction to most cosmologists
opinions to scientists have found evidence that universe that the universe may
have existed forever.
There has been no big bang and then it's just constant and it goes on forever
and it never ends,
which is what I've always thought was right.
I mean,
I know I'm an idiot and I shouldn't be commenting on what cosmologists day,
but I always felt like our need for anything to be beginning and ending.
And so we can wrap our heads around it cause we be,
we begin and end based on her own biological limitations.
We think that someone thing has to have a birth and,
and,
and it's also like can come the game over.
It's like where do you go after the interspace?
Where do you go after that?
So where do you have to have your die?
Nothing weird are they weren't your time man.
We're learning some shit about the universe and learning some shit about just
reality that no human beings have ever been able to wrap their heads around.
You know,
I had a conversation with someone the other day about,
you know,
how people,
they were talking about Egyptians and how much of the Egyptian people new to be
able to create those structures.
And I'm like,
yeah,
it probably was pretty interesting.
But I guaran t you,
we know more now so much more than knew some crazy shit.
They knew how to build some amazing structures that we can't quite wrap our
heads around today.
But believe me,
everything gets more complex from the beginning of the universe,
from the beginning of life on this planet,
from,
you know,
the fucking birth of our star.
Everything has gotten more and more weird and always wellbeing.
You go to those mountains in Colorado,
you hike up those mountains.
Don't make me homesick.
Profit.
You see some shit up in those mountains and you've got to think that totally.
Years ago there was water here.
It was water here.
My thing is this is never began.
And start with a bull.
Civilizations of coming eight times on this same fucking planet is at least
illegally.
We vented with an 80 year wards route,
whatever shooted,
you know,
can start it with a cannon ball.
And it just kept evolving.
We have paperwork to document this back to Jesus.
Now,
you know,
there's always one gun.
It ends up like fucking your buddy there.
The Scientologists,
the Black Dude,
that movie go Henry where he lived at a fucking cave himself with a German
shepherd.
Will Smith,
uh,
goal,
whatever.
Be,
what's his name?
I am legend.
You know,
and all of a sudden he meets a Brody Fox and then four people and then we go on.
And your Grandpa,
you know,
I,
I don't think we just existed,
died.
I always think that there's been a bunch of different versions of humanity,
different versions of humanity.
Man.
We've talked about Graham Hancock on this podcast a bunch of times,
but if you ever want to get into that folks,
there's a guy named Graham Hancock who wrote a book called fingerprints of the
Gods.
He wrote a bunch of books.
Underworld is another one that deals with all these different cities that they
found underneath the ocean.
Please.
There's so many different structures.
Man's giant structures,
rows and shit.
They're,
the earth used to be used to have a much lower level of sea level.
The sea level was much lower and uh,
we had much more ice everywhere and that ice melted at a certain point in time
with what we're worried about today.
Everyone's worried about global warming,
but off the ice caps melt.
That shit has happened so many times over the course of humanity and there's all
this evidence for these cities that are in the ocean has shifted.
You have brought a point up that they found fucking,
this is a loan right here.
I had a thought.
I had just,
this makes my hypothesis stronger.
You said that they found the tooth in Montana of a dinosaur that lived only a
megalodons sharp believe used ago.
I don't know the info,
but right there.
What the fuck with the shark doing in the mountains of Montana,
that's one of the best places to find a negligible.
That's what I'm saying.
That was covered at one time and one civilization a long,
long fucking time ago before the Chinese even existed and came over and built
the railroad tracks.
There was a complete different civilization here.
Totally.
Well,
you know Chinese were over here before anybody that,
yes,
they were yesterday,
weren't found Chinese bones.
The oldest bones have ever found in North America from a Chinese person that was
in 10,000 years ago.
Believe it dog.
I believe it.
That's my native place shit show.
It's,
it's,
you know,
well the Indians,
we know that they came from Asia to,
that's what the Indians came from.
You know,
or you know,
native Americans,
you should say.
Yeah.
Hawaii always freaks me out the most,
man.
When you think that this is fairly recent,
you know,
in terms of like millions of years,
you know this,
this volcano erupted in the middle of the ocean,
not near anything.
And there's all these motherfuckers just,
you know how those countries are populated,
they go from one island and they take canoes and to another island.
They can't even see.
They don't even know it's there.
They just started canoeing out.
Yeah.
And they did it back before gps,
before they did,
I don't even think fucking folders.
You didn't,
they went to her to a cylinder,
going to gps.
They didn't give a fuck.
They got a blanket and took a chance.
You know what I'm saying?
Go East cock suck.
They do that.
The Polynesians,
like there's people that originally found Hawaii.
No wonder whether select like adamant about it being,
there's you imagine how hard it was to get there and you bitches are cheating by
getting on a Delta flight and coming over to your stupid fucking flower shirt
with the Polynesian cove.
I don't know the whole area.
I don't know where that bone,
I was a kid.
There was a Polynesian restaurant,
my name,
but the Mike caught up.
Motherfucker used to kick that place.
We kicked,
they have a bartender have movie karate chop.
He let you karate chop them.
They were the only joint that would have spare ribs.
And the thing we got to go get some Cuban.
We've got to go to verse size and Encino.
Soon.
Dot is another places.
A couple of good places for sizes.
Good.
That chicken soup they have and that garlic chicken with onions.
We'll talk cause another person to the side.
Then this other one I Venice we're signed.
There's,
I dunno.
Well they're all like,
cause I've only eaten at the one in Encino.
All different.
They've got a one in silver lake.
That's tremendous.
So coaching Ito never trust the people that make shitty food,
man.
Countries that foods with foods not tasting the fuck's wrong Weirdos.
Yeah,
you born cuts.
Oh that's the first way you got to like people is to their food.
Like just fucking Spaghetti's goals.
The case with English anymore though.
English restaurants,
there's a lot of dope restaurants in England,
in London I guess too.
They have a good food.
All kinds of food.
It's like,
you know,
you hear about it like that's the old cliche like from Bill Hicks and material,
but English food being bad.
But I've had some great English food is a lot of great restaurants in now go
over there and a bunch of different places,
you know,
like that's what we are.
Or is it just food,
food,
you know there's like,
you know,
fine restaurants.
They're working on that passport.
England,
Australia come Aveda,
you motherfuckers within a year.
Is that possible?
I Bro,
don't worry about nothing.
I made a call and let us show you if you want to go right now.
Black,
can you go working on it right now?
So don't keep twitting me on.
But what happens when you,
when they land,
I'm going to have to break away from you and hide.
That's fine.
You're don't have to shine your on on nothing.
I got Cardi Bravo had a gun charge from when he was younger.
When he used to work for a check cashing company.
It's totally legit and legal.
He had the gun on him because he worked for a dangerous United dangerous job is
transporting,
are this all this cash around.
And he got pulled over and he told the cops,
you know,
I have a gun on me.
And they arrested him and even though he'd nothing happened and they cleared him
of it,
every time he goes to Canada,
they fuck them with it.
Wow.
Every time takes hours.
And now I'm like,
yeah,
you go ahead,
go.
Go ahead dude.
I love Canada,
but I can't go to that.
You guys don't,
don't know what to fucking work with people.
You know what I'm saying?
And when I went up there,
you guys are vented delivery.
We,
20 years ago,
nobody was doing delivery.
We'd like give you motherfucking Canadians prompts.
You guys do a delivery right there to blow a street.
I stayed in a hotel and I was doing whatever.
Well I completely understand candidates stance.
If you are a country that's filled with predominently friendly,
nice people,
law abiding citizens for the most part,
like their percentage of criminals and scumbags is way lower than ours.
They exist but it's a way lower number and you live next to a country that's
just fucking savages,
savages and criminals that are looking at scape law enforcement by sneaking into
the next door neighbor country,
which is really nice and filled with suite people.
So you know they had to react that way but so many people must've been sneaking
over from fucking Detroit in New York and criminals,
scumbags and murderers and douchebags.
Meanwhile Canada is like one of the nicest places in the fucking world and it's
our neighbor but they,
the flavor they do once lady blow street,
Blood Street was the only place ever I went down and went to a strip club cause
I'll even go to strip clubs.
These things.
I went to a strip club and the girl put her monkey in my face and I believe at a
club on blustery.
What's the,
okay.
She put her monkey in my and I'd been in a fucking monkey issue.
[inaudible] going big,
big,
big.
I remember that.
The monkey drove me crazy.
I went back to the Strip club.
I got up,
I went back to the comedy club before they closed,
got another $150 draw and went back at $10 a lap dance.
I sniffed her asshole and this is why going on in an American place,
you go to Canada stuff,
the girls asked for $10 they are lacking data.
Labor though as far as you got motherfucker label,
let me and signed the paperwork.
This is what it is.
It's like some flavor up there.
North Toronto,
North America is like the three bears like Mama Bear,
baby bear and papa bear.
That's what it's like.
And like Mexico,
too much flavor.
[inaudible] states the right amount of flavor.
Canada,
not enough flavor.
It's like Mexico's got too much.
They're too fucking crazy.
I tell you what I'm ready for though.
Well,
at this point in my life,
I'm ready for England.
Are you ready?
I'm going to go there and I want the people,
I went the fuck motherfuckers from snatch to pick me up at the airport.
The two black dudes and the other fucking Jewish.
You could go to England because I would love to take you to someone was loud
rock you mother.
You guys know it.
Dave bishop has retired from comedy.
He's out.
Did I tell you what happened?
Oh my goodness.
We were in England and Dave,
I love him to death.
Uh,
he apparently hadn't been doing that much comedy and he went on stage and you
know,
so rowdy,
crazy drunk crowd and uh,
they were fired up and he just was like,
I was in the dressing room like for like six minutes.
I was going over my notes and all of a sudden,
Dave's at the door.
You Ready?
Joe?
And I go,
ready?
I go,
what's going on?
How come,
you know,
on stage?
He goes,
ah,
I couldn't get him.
You couldn't get him who's on stage?
No one time stage.
So he did six minutes and just bailed.
Gone off stage,
came back to the green room to get me and I was like,
oh no dude,
like what's going on?
So I went on stage.
I'm like,
Hey,
what's come on folks?
And I didn't know what to say.
That's crazy.
Yeah it was.
It was ridiculous.
The show.
It's great.
They were awesome.
You know what man,
here's the deal.
When you reach a certain point in your life,
and he did,
he's got a job and he's had a job forever.
He works in a full time job at a bank.
You know,
and I've said this and this is just the fact,
if you want to be a fucking comic,
the saying,
there's no safe place.
The saying no part time job,
it ain't easy.
You're going to have to immerse yourself in the world of comedy.
You gotta become a fucking comedy soldier.
You can do it if you can do it at all.
If you can do it and can go up there and get laughs,
you can get better.
If you can get better,
you can get become a professional.
If you could probably become professional,
you could become a good professional.
You could become a headline.
You could become a TV act.
You can be a stand up comedian,
but it's not going to be fucking easy,
man.
And you're not going to do it while you have a regular job.
But I need my dental now.
You don't need your dental.
You gotta.
You gotta fucking move.
We got insurance.
Cock sucker looked at me.
It's my whole thing is missing.
I got nice teeth that look like fucking Humphrey Bogart.
That's easy to say though.
It's,
there's no movies being booked in fucking,
you know Manchester.
Yeah.
Nice to hang out at the store late night.
It's still all the fucking cell phones from the office of black boots downtown.
I used to fucking give out tickets.
I used to give out the stubs.
It's the peak they were doing and I would get dial up a ticket.
I pick
up an extra 300 a week upstairs.
Mitzi show me pulling out.
We got a bed.
You gotta know how to work the fucking deal?
No.
Joey would have robbed the shit out of Brian and robbed me.
Suck my dick
sucked his down.
I can set right dick.
I would've made your pass out.
Yeah.
How would I gave you a weed?
Y'All hot with a blown up.
You would've passed that.
You would've woke up nothing with a bit.
Then you would have had another fucking anxiety attacks to [inaudible] on one
night and woke up with a department full of tropical helmet.
Yeah,
you would have minus the Tivo and 800 and fucking ambulance charges.
What's the most you had to pay for ambulances for picking up like that?
Probably don't want the last one.
The last one.
Well,
the whole thing costs $4,000
with insurance.
Fucking a,
Oh my God.
With insurance.
Sacrifice myself.
Eat everybody.
Yeah.
Much Day Yama.
Stay right.
Keep it together.
If you ever have something like that happened,
all she can fuck.
Call me.
Absolutely.
I'll come rescue you.
I'll save you.
I'm gonna hold your hand.
We're going to get through this pitches.
I'll come over.
Scare the fuck out of you.
You understand me all for one United health,
whatever it is.
The more time we did ask and went to see apocalypse now be junk crowds,
Chris de Lorenzo,
when it first came out,
the first weekend I was about 16 it was amazing on the walk home,
which is walking my little business just raved and all of a sudden this,
there's that.
I keep talking to my friend,
I keep saying to him,
do you hear those sirens?
And my buddy's like,
I hear him play,
he's playing along with me.
And I'm like,
you hit a sign was like,
yeah.
And honestly the one guy's like,
I don't hear nothing.
Nothing,
man.
I swear to God,
I'll fucking hit him like,
you know,
here.
And we started covering our ears and shit.
And then we went up to somebody.
You hear those sirens?
And he's like,
yeah.
And we even freaked out now because somebody else is here with him.
And this poor kid looked around and had just rained.
There was a puddle on the street.
I'll never forget.
He got his hands and knees and started throwing.
The puddle
is probably like shy gasoline on the surface.
He just got up and ran the fuck home.
We've seen him like a two days later.
He's like,
man,
I kept hearing those sirens on.
I saw apocalypse now.
I really watched the whole movie was in this house when I first bought this
house,
when I first bought this,
because it's got,
I got to like a movie theater,
like a hundred inch,
you know,
thing that drops down and I ate a pop cookie and I'm stoned as balls.
Everyone's asleep at me and I'm sitting there watching this apocalypse now in
this giant 100 inch screen and that's when it hit me.
What a brilliant piece of filmmaking that move release.
There's certain movies,
man,
where you watch the movie and go damn movies.
Just a work of art.
You know?
It's like they just took you on a journey.
There's so much about that movie,
like the end when they're killing the bowl,
like there's so much about that movie.
Like you couldn't even do that today because they really killed a bull and
filmed it.
I mean,
they hacked that fucking boiled to death.
Right.
That was real shit.
That wasn't special effect on these like disturbing and shocking and the whole
Marlon Brando is this fucking insane general gone off his rocker.
The whole thing was amazing,
man.
That is a God damn movie man.
The sound,
everything.
Robert Duvall,
Charlie don't surf that.
We'll see when he goes in and the black dudes listen to Hendrix and I can't even
imagine on a big screen by by month to jump out of fucks ripping balls.
The CEO here,
whatever he says,
surround sound speakers all around my head,
everywhere.
He was one of those real motherfucking black dudes with the veins in the eyes in
Detroit.
We open the fucking black dude in Memphis,
Detroit thing.
I'm phasing it in what phase?
The eyelid member.
They asked them,
they said to him,
well,
who's the capitol?
The and he looked around this motherfucker,
looked them buckler no
motherfucker.
He don't even have to say that.
That was intense.
He just looked at it all gone off the deep end,
all God,
how many people?
That movie really kind of captured what a lot of people felt about war that does
this.
A lot of crazy shit going down.
It wasn't as simple as everyone marching
going rogue man.
A lot of nutty shit.
Some fucking knowledge jobs give people,
this is a true story.
One day be roughly manager.
I would around skin stone,
we go round,
we've got to catch this weed store.
It's on Formosa and Santa Monica.
They got really good edibles.
So we pull over,
Ralphie may can't find a parking spot.
It's 20 to fucking eight seven 35 the place closes at eight so we're going to go
to a movie.
And so I was saying I go roughly just dropped me off here and parked the car and
I'll get on in there.
So I walk in and there's a line.
So the guy wouldn't let me in.
They check ids outside the street at this place.
This is right across the street from the Formosa Cafe.
So while I'm waiting in line,
there's a girl in front of me and I'm waiting there could hoof and I'm stones
and I'm going in there to get more.
And who fucking walks up to me?
Who's walking down the street smoking a cigarette.
But Lawrence Mother Fishburg got Dan,
he goes,
what are you doing?
And I,
he goes,
don't use a comedian on showtime.
I had a thing,
I'll get the fuck ass too.
I told him,
he goes and with San Juan fucked me up talking to,
and he's talking about,
it's awesome.
So who comes walking up from a distance is Ralphie may Wallen up and I can see
that as he's walking up,
bro.
He's looking at me,
but he's like,
what the fuck you talking [inaudible] mother fucking fit by the fuck did you,
did Ralphie start talking black to him?
No,
Ralph.
We just started talking to them at Laurence Fishburne told us about that movie.
They have his voice will vary in blackness
for,
he was doing dog,
he was 14 when they took him to the Philippines to shoot that movie.
Yeah.
So next time you see when he was 17 when they finished,
right for this next time you see Laurence Fishburne,
you shake his hand,
you're going to listen.
I only met him once at Skybar but very brief.
I didn't even know.
Didn't even meet him.
I shouldn't say I met him.
I was in his presence.
You would in the Philippines when you afford team,
most kids don't make it back.
You got to feel bad for that guy,
man.
He's got a 19 year old daughter that's doing ghetto.
Paul shows up at the store sometimes.
Really not that attractive.
Not that attractive in her ass is filled with doubt.
It's like weird.
She's got like little,
these little zits all over ass.
It's weird.
You know like like someone shot her with like rock salt.
I hate
that shit.
You would go to a strip club and the chick would have her on her own.
A little tight white head.
You want to pop that one?
I pop that on.
How you want to give it like a 10 let me pop that pimple walking around wounded
here.
That little white kid on your ass is killing me.
She's got hail damage on her ass.
No,
no.
There's this sadness man and having a 19 year old daughter and being some
superstar movie star and you know,
I mean from the fucking matrix and so many goddamn movies.
King in New York member him at King in New York.
How good was he in that fucking movie?
That was a great movie.
Man Walks this does give the kids money at the shop and he stole them all.
Here you go by yourself.
This is shit.
Yet he was caught on at Belk.
I turned to that was,
oh yeah.
Hey Man.
Herb bullshit or fucking one eight.
What is you doing man?
Is he doing a TV show or something like that?
What is the budget of 50 g a week on CSI though?
Cause he doing that CSI,
it's almost seems like that those guys to get to a certain age.
This one,
let me just take a show.
Women just live at home.
I live in New York or wherever city.
We're doing this in the house enough.
All this flying somewhere for three months and going somewhere else for four
months.
Some of the guys do like Kevin,
Kevin,
James,
man,
he uproots every six,
six months or so goes live somewhere for a few months and stuff.
Yeah.
When I,
when I did that,
a zookeeper movie with him,
he's got this sweet and Boston in a hotel.
It's like his apartment.
He's been there for a month.
I could see doing it too,
like going from movies to a TV show,
go like let me do this for just for a few years.
We just relax for a few years.
He shows her the best gig in town.
Man when I did news radio,
if you're,
if you're into acting,
if you want to be an actor,
that's the best gig in town because he,
once he gets it down to a science,
like once news radio got down to a science,
we really only worked four days a week,
you know,
and we filmed one of them and we would take a day off and once the writers got
really in tune,
you know,
they would come out with killer scripts.
Like on the first go,
like when you get in like third and fourth season,
everything becomes like a smooth machine.
You know,
you know how to do it.
And those are,
those are the best gigs,
man.
You don't have to go nowhere.
Dave Foley used to always say that.
He used to always say,
this is the best Gig in show business.
Don't ever forget it.
This is the best Gig in show business that pour fuck.
He's been twittering lately.
He's been tweeting lately about his first wife.
He's uh,
he's not making money these days,
not making much money.
And his wife took him to court for alimony and the judge ordered that he pay
three times his monthly salary.
What he makes a month.
Right now he has to pay his wife three times that.
And the judge said that his obligation to pay is not related to his ability to
pay.
Like he has an obligation to pay and it has no bearing on his ability to pay and
they won't make an adjustment.
It's like an Ottawa.
You know in Canada they got some wacky laws up there.
Cause I remember when he got divorced,
it was nuts man.
When he first got divorced when we were on news radio and he was making a ton of
money and his wife had access to his finances for a year.
Because what happens is in,
in Canada the laws are totally different where you know for if one year you
can't get divorced,
you have to be separated for one year before they allow you to get divorced,
which is crazy.
Wow.
I don't know if they're trying to keep families together or what,
but in Dave's case it was worst case scenario.
So here's the wife with money and she's traveling all over the world with his
money buying furniture going off and she was going,
I remember he had to go to Egypt so he had to take all this malaria medication
and he lost his marbles.
Once he got hammered,
we were at one of these press parties and shit and he's on malaria medication,
which apparently does not mix well with vodka,
which they're just drinking out of his head.
Man.
Took some reporters tape recorder and stuck it in his drink and he doesn't even
remember doing it and he was just like hallucinating and show like malaria
medicine is,
no,
no fucking joke man.
But the whole thing is,
it highlights another thing about how crazy marriages man,
how he hasn't been with this woman in a long time.
I still owes her.
Yeah.
Not Just Ozer Ozer exorbitant amounts of money.
He's responsible for maintaining her lifestyle even though his lifestyle is not
the same anymore.
He's connected to her even though he's not in her life anymore.
Sorry.
Before where it's like,
I don't make as much in common,
but I still owe them based on what I used to.
They don't give a fuck.
It's crazy,
man.
It is not set up for you,
dude.
It's not set up for you.
It's set up to make sure that the woman doesn't get fucked over.
But in so doing,
they've set it up so the man gets fucked over some times now for some time.
Sometimes it's good because some dudes are douche bags and they don't wanna pay
for their kids.
Fuck them.
They should.
They should be paying money.
They hide money in child support is totally different than alimony.
But you know,
look,
I have another friend who got married.
He was married for over 15 years,
I believe it was before we got divorced.
He had no prenup.
He has to pay his ex wife alimony for the rest of her life.
Wow.
Four F RLS and needs a lot of money because he was wealthy.
He was very wealthy,
so he is paying her stupid amounts of money.
So it just drives him nuts and he can't live the way he wants to live,
even though he makes good money.
He made,
it doesn't make as much money as you used to,
but it makes a lot of money.
But he can't live the way he wants to because he has this giant nut he has to
pay,
has to pay every month.
Chiott crazy.
Dot.
Just thousands and thousands and thousands of thousands.
It's just what the numbers are just flying in this chick's bank account.
As you're writing that check,
you get busy.
Oh,
he gets busy talking about fucking busy.
You know what I'm saying?
Red Lips.
Quivered man,
when he talks about his lips quiver,
when they tell you about it,
naturally slips quiver and he's married now and he's gotten,
he's got kids and shit still still has to pay mad,
mad loot.
You look at that fucking knife once a month,
they have a narrow dizzy.
It's crazy.
And the only way,
it's not like you can get like,
listen,
how about I just give you $2 million?
And we don't talk ever again.
No,
no,
no.
It's a million a year.
3 million here.
Whatever the fuck it is.
You should go on forever.
It's like visa.
I miss a month to see what the fuck.
Half good.
Lots of money on our own.
We got the fellow an animal.
Oh,
fucking crisis.
Isn't it funny that you could crush that and throw it on the floor and I
wouldn't even think you're being rude,
but if you kill the rat and threw it on the floor,
I'd be like,
hey dude,
clean that out or something.
The size.
Yeah,
the little tiny baby.
And I'm like,
I don't care about that little ant body on my grandpa.
Insignificant.
But if it was bigger,
it was like a big giant beat on you.
Stomped on it,
then I'd have to pick
her up.
It's all relative pitches.
It's all relative.
And with the music provided by Joey beat box Diaz,
we don't bring you to the conclusion of this podcast.
Ari Shapiro show tonight at the Improv used to be in the Improv lab.
What?
It got too strong things up.
Move it up like the Jeffersons.
Motherfucker.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the Jefferson.
So these stories will be taking place.
If I could sneak out of the house,
I'm going to go there as well.
Red Band,
follow him on Twitter.
N Ari Shaffir.
Follow him on Twitter.
Mad Flavor is Joey Diaz.
Who would it be at the show today?
Book Twitter,
Facebook.
Check yourself before you wreck yourself.
Big Dixon gas is bad for your health.
Stay black and beach pop yet we got it going on the fucking showed them on.
I thank you to the pot.
Louie.
Is it to the fleshlight fleshlight for supporting our show.
Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link.
Use The comp Promo Code Rogan and you get 50 [inaudible] cock sucker.
Duncan Trussell and I are in Montreal at the comedy works.
Oh Shit.
Mad sold out for months in advance.
Sorry,
you can't get tickets home,
but you can see me,
Joe Dsrs Fair.
What are you doing now?
February four Superbowl weekend.
Merry Christmas bitches.
Happier.
We should fears on the show as well.
That's how we push with the death squad.
Stay Black,
Huh?
The most important thing you should ever get out of this podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen,
as you see the circle of friends,
we surround ourselves with a bunch of cool,
positive people.
You can have this too.
If you are one of those and you bring in people like that,
you'd get it together.
A tight knit group of bad motherfuckers in your life could be a masterpiece.
Okay?
Or just have good people,
good people come.
People had all that positive energy.
You would track this shit.
This is like the secret.
Look at what we've attracted to design this fucking show.
I am thankful.
If I'm thankful for anything.
I have bad motherfuckers for friends.
My friends aren't.
Give me some knuckles.
You bitches.
I love you guys.
I love you people out there.
Oh,
you bitches.
I love all you bitches.
I love all 211,000 Twitter friends,
53,000 Facebook friends.
I even love you fucking Weirdos that are still on my space.
My space is making a comeback.
Joe Rogan making a comeback.
I don't give a fuck what they say tomorrow night coffee be,
what time is it,
Brian?
Uh,
it's going to be around three o'clock ish,
three o'clock ish.
We're going to do the cliffy be podcast tomorrow and I,
cliff,
you be from Edelman and I was brave prosecuting.
Give us some scopes about gears of war and unreal tournament and all kinds of
crazy shit.
And perhaps we even play some video games.
Brian's got shit set up.
It's gonna be crazy.
All right.
That's it.
That's the end of the show.
I love you bitches.
You guys
found your God.
I want to get super low sale
touch when I drink too much.
No,
it's may made food me.
I'll try to reconcile and I apologize
[inaudible].